those in the hospital for my Olympia
prep at about four weeks out for a week
I thought everything was gonna be taken
away from me
Champion mentality it's not about
winning it's not about a trophy it's
about having no quit
I could have a thousand bullet points on
her Champion mentality but I used to
look up to people and I said do you like
Michael Jordan but that's not [__] me
there's no rules to being a champion
breaking that stigma that like both can
coexist in a alpha male too from that
you know like you can be this [__]
killer who cries you know like you can't
you know Champion makes his own rules
and rides up the wave like that
Chris Bumstead welcome to the show thank
you grateful to be here they're excited
what does pressure is a privilege mean
wow you really dive into this quick eh
so casual then you just stare me in the
eye and ask the first question
is a privilege is definitely something
that like evolved over of time I think I
first heard it from Tim Grover which is
someone who kind of like his book
Relentless put my mindset into like the
focus on my mindset and competing rather
than just my physical body because I
knew that's what it would take to like
get to the next level and I think after
winning in Olympia I was like oh [__]
like I just showed my cards I had people
know what I'm capable of now there's no
one I gotta beat there's no like
second place third place like flow it's
like no you're the best and unless
you're the best we just forget about you
so it's like this pressure I felt on
myself and it was coming externally for
a while and I was trying to like
understand how I could gravitate that a
little bit better without it kind of
bringing me down and slowing down my
progress and I had to kind of function
into the reality that the pressure was
really coming from myself rather than
externally and that it's a good pressure
it's a pressure to be better and to
become the best version of myself and
it's something that if I choose to use
it properly it's going to push me to be
a better version of myself to grow
mentally physically in my relationships
however I want it to let me grow if I
choose to take control of the aspects I
have control over so in essence it's the
more pressure you have on you and if you
take it as a privilege it's a choice to
put your perception of the privilege
rather than a burden and by taking the
power back in that choice it pushes you
in a direction of being better rather
than holding you back yeah there's
a pain that comes from the expectation
of success I suppose which is different
to your first time you know when you've
got nothing to prove you have nothing to
lose the Underdog's always the finest is
that the way that you found it
I mean I definitely the beginning of my
career was just I never even had
aspirations to be Mr Olympia when I said
I just love to train love to body build
and then once I started to get that
pressure on me that started to fade a
bit because I was taking in so much
outside noise and I stopped doing it for
the right reasons of why I started and
just the fact that I love it and I joy
and I enjoy pushing my body to the
limits so that affected me for a bit
but even like my first ever Olympia win
because of other stuff I had gone
through I actually didn't even really
enjoy it because of like stress of my
health and pressure somebody had gone
through the year before all this like
not being present and suppressing all my
like fears I had around it I just like
battled through it got there and I was
like
it's over like I just won Olympia this
is the goal I've been chasing like for
six seven years specifically in the
league I have it and now I why do I feel
like I'm missing something and I think I
kind of uncovered that I was suppressing
all this pressure all this fear of my
health all these other aspects and in
doing so I was also suppressing my
ability to fear Joy feel joy and
excitement and the positive side of
things because you always hear you can't
like selectively numb emotions yeah
they're pretty much numb everything or
you feel all of it and I was definitely
a numbing kind of guy I was like [__] I
don't feel it pushing the side
compartmentalize and get to work and I
was just like okay no this isn't right
something's got to change and those two
years my came second the year before got
sick won that Olympian didn't enjoy it
this is like all right physical stuff is
down I won I gotta focus on my mental
side right now because I if I'm doing
this I want to love it I started because
I love it and I want to keep doing it
because I love it I'll remember the uh
Conor McGregor was talking about I think
the first time that he won the interim
title and then the second time that he
beat Aldo in 13 seconds and before that
fight which seemed to be kind of peak
McGregor right he was just this Savant
like an artist of war and uh someone was
asking him what are you going to do
differently this time that he didn't do
last time and he said I'm going to enjoy
it yep because he stepped out on stage
and there's that famous photo of him and
he stood like this yeah looking out at
the weigh-in just feels it and he said
he can barely remember it yeah he's
[__] amazing you know the photo I
mean he's still there and he's got that
tattoo up the back of his yeah
and he said I can barely remember it um
and he got another bite at the Apple
yeah he got to do it again that's that's
like and that's a huge part of my life
again like getting sick I felt like I
was gonna have to stop competing and
then I won that Olympia and then I'm
like okay now I have the opportunity to
do this again right like that's an
absolute blessing like I'm so grateful
that now I get to do it again and I've
done it four times and I'm going for a
fifth like the fact that I've had four
years to like enjoy it more and prep and
like perfect my craft it's just like
it's something I'm like counting my days
that I'm grateful for every single
morning so it makes it more fun I've
heard you say that winning is not what I
once thought it was I have found it to
be much more complex than our
traditional definitions of success
what's that mean
it comes from
when I was younger just like wanting
more stuff a lot of external stuff a lot
of success again things out of your
control I wanted like circumstances and
objects I wanted success thinking of
something I could like the world could
give me rather than something I could
give myself and I look at winning as
success it's kind of one in the same and
there's this awesome quote by I think
Jim Jim Carrey and it goes I wish for
the world to realize all of their dreams
so that they can realize they don't make
them complete and he's talking about
that most people's dreams are very like
external like Champions like they want
to win a medal though when a trophy want
a nice car and all this stuff then you
get it and when you have everything you
realize this isn't what I wanted I Don't
Feel Complete right now and I have the
amazing opportunity in my life to have
accomplished so many of my dreams and
realize that there's still a void
missing there the more money I get the
more titles I get the more I get it's
not filling me up more but then I
discovered that over time like it's the
effort it's the journey it's like
suffering through time that I don't want
to be at the gym or why I want to quit
on my diet and I push myself and every
single moment every day leading up to
the show and I win all those moments
that's winning that's like winning in
life continuously every day and through
that Journey being able to build my
relationships not sacrifice them for
winning be able to make myself a better
person not a more stressed out anxious
person all that stuff coming together
I've already won before I have a trophy
in my hands when I stand on stage I
haven't quitting on the workout I
haven't quit my cardio session my
girlfriend still loves me in the
background she doesn't hate me for
neglecting her for the last three months
of prep I'm like I won you know like I
feel [__] good right now and I'm like
if I lose am I going to leave him be
really sad and like cry and like grieve
that loss absolutely but I'm still gonna
be proud of everything I put in and at
the end of the day that's all I can
control and to me that's winning
how much do you think the joy of winning
is just relief and a brief respite from
fear of not being enough a lot of it a
lot of it and I've talked to other
people who have won things before and
myself and that first Olympia with a
test of that like the biggest thing I
felt was just relief I'm like [__] I did
it's over okay you can relax I'm not a
loser I'm not a piece of [__] yeah
that's like that Excel and then
a day or two goes by or a week or
something you're like I gotta do that
again but better if I ever want to feel
like that again there's expectations on
me now I have to do more and I have to
do better I have to be better I have to
work harder I have to take myself to the
limits and further because now that's my
standard and now I need to overcome that
standard to really impress anyone like
the whole thing is showing your cards as
soon as someone knows you're good or how
good you are that's a baseline you have
to be better than that to be like okay
so how what is your advice to someone
that is struggling with the pressure of
success perhaps you know for a long time
they've been thinking that they want to
get to a place then they set a standard
and now they realize this pain of having
to meet that standard again how have you
managed to balance
these two uh these two worlds the desire
to continue to be better yeah and also
the requirement to be able to be
grateful and enjoy the present moment
I think on one aspect and something that
is very strange I think for people to
hear because a lot of Champions we hear
are just like killer mentality like win
at all costs I think on one aspect I've
accepted that I'd be okay with losing I
accepted that if I lost like I said I
would grieve I would be sad it would
suck but like life would go on I would
be okay and the Olympia is a huge part
of my life but it's not everything part
of my life so kind of giving myself
permission to fail in essence almost
gives myself permission to try harder
and maybe it's not like that for
everybody but for myself as soon as I
was like okay if this happened then I
lose what then like I either quit and
leave and move on with my life or I come
back and I try harder and that motivates
me for more but either way I'm still me
I still have who I am as a person that I
always control I have my relationship to
people I love around me and a lot of
beautiful stuff going on my life so like
I'm gonna be okay and that really just
kind of alleviate a lot of pressure and
gave me permission to perform even more
a lot of people are afraid to even try
hard because then if you try hard and
you fail you feel like a failure but the
aspect of being a failure doesn't come
from the success in the end it comes
from if you really quit on yourself or
if you don't put in the effort you know
you can put in and you're kind of
holding back on your true potential
that's what I think you really deep down
feel like a failure like underneath your
soul yeah this some interesting uh
trends at the moment that I'm noticing
and one of them is something I've called
the cynicism safety blanket that's what
you're talking about now I think
cynicism is a guarded response which
sets yourself up against disappointment
its role within the system is to protect
you against experiencing anything bad it
is a preemptive strike against a
perceived threat if I tell myself that
all women are bad then I'm less likely
to seek a relationship with women and as
a consequence I'm never going to feel
the pain of rejection if I tell myself
that everything is [__] or that things
will never get better then I'm excused
of ever having to try at anything it is
more comfortable to get fatalistic and
call it pragmatism the cope is framing
hope is pathetic and embarrassing and
optimism as delusion it's sour grapes at
an existential level if everything sucks
and everyone is terrible and reality is
disappointing and you know that for a
fact then it's the people acting like
things can be better that are dumb
delusional and the problem the upside of
never having to try is never having to
feel the pain of failure I think that's
what you're talking about yeah very much
so and I think that even that applies to
all aspects of life and what really
pushed me to like learn these lessons
again I'm not like a psychologist or
educated like that but I've lived a lot
of life and I've had a lot of ups and
downs and in 2018 I've diagnosed with an
autoimmune disease I was in the hospital
for my Olympia prep at about four weeks
out for a week and I came out and I
didn't know if I was gonna be able to
compete I didn't know if I'd be even
healthy ever again I thought everything
was going to be taken away from me and I
got through it I came second at that
Olympia somehow and it was like a battle
to the death of numbing everything and
just suppressing anything I feel and
just trying to focus on bodybuilding and
I did that for about a year and a half
and this whole mindset I built around it
was this fear that I'm gonna get sick
again I need to quit bodybuilding
because I'm gonna get sick I don't have
control over my health I'm gonna get
sick and I'm just this constant fear of
looming over my head because if I got
sick then I could be like I knew I'd get
sick you know like it was good it was
bound for everything to be taken away
from me it almost happened last year
it's gonna happen next year and I was
just living in that secrete almost
prepare myself to create a little safety
blanket like you said to just be okay
when it happens I can say I told you so
I was right and I'm ready for it rather
than leaning into actually enjoying life
and kind of moving past that so I had to
really like reframe my mindset and I
started to I went through this whole
journey of like after that I turned into
you won't get sick trying to convince
myself I'm not gonna get sick denial
exactly but then you're living in a
sense of lack and avoidance and then
you're also constantly thinking of that
and when you're thinking of that
constantly [__] about your body in this
state of reaction or you're waiting for
something to happen and when something
happens you know like [__] it's against
what I keep telling myself and then I
switch to telling myself no you are
healthy instead of saying nothing and
lack what do you want be like you are
healthy you are going to be okay all
this stuff and then that still didn't
really make me feel better because I'm
still kind of Unknowing and then I
literally came to the conclusion that I
don't [__] know like the only truth
right now is that I don't know what's
gonna happen but there are measures I
can take to take control of my health as
best as I can and the rest is up to the
universe but if the more I stress about
the more I think about it it's creating
more this state of reaction myself is
taking me out of the present moment to
be able to enjoy and perform the way I
know I can I'm not able to enjoy it and
I still Battle of course sometimes I
didn't just forget about it but just the
understanding and Baseline that I don't
know the future so I have to let go of
some of those things the only thing that
really helped my mind get through all
that times and I mean continuously now
when I compete and I'm like am I gonna
get sick be like I don't know but when
it happens you're gonna deal with it and
you'll be okay so just enjoy this moment
right now what's your inner voice like
now because I've heard you talk about
battles with depression and anxiety in
the past that's something that I dealt
with throughout all of my 20s as well
and
me reflecting on
the change in the texture of my own mind
through a lot of self-work and a lot of
external work too like I can't pretend
like the external accolades of the world
me proving to the world and the world
saying that yes you are good enough
because the things that you have applied
yourself to have been uh you've been
given the the rewards that you wanted
um but yeah what what's your inner voice
like now as someone who used to deal
with depression and anxiety
I was definitely more leaning into the
anxious more rather than depressed and
that with more like just just projecting
the future based off unhealed wound from
the past and fears what happened the
past was going to repeat itself
but now I think my inner voice is just
and it's a constant work I'm doing I
think mental health in general is like
putting in reps it's not just like oh
I'm good it's like continuously giving
yourself the love you need mentally and
physically and I'm just trying to build
a lot more empathy and compassion for
myself because I didn't directly shame
myself being like you're not good enough
you're a piece of [__] all this [__] but
I would be like I expected more of
myself like we were talking with public
speaking I'm like you just won four
Olympians and now you're literally like
heart racing can barely breathe because
you're about to talk in front of like a
few hundred people like you should be
able to do this you're better than this
and that's a form of shame in itself of
expecting something out of myself that
maybe I'm not ready for or just rather
than accepting who I am and where I'm at
my life so I think just building that
compassion and being like accepting who
I am and who I am isn't what this like
this perception that maybe people have
built with me and you know I believe you
had this guy on Peter Crone I love that
guy yeah he has his quote and he says
life presents you as people and
circumstances to show you where you're
not free and I think that the way I
spoke about my inner voice and this
expectation of myself with where I
wasn't free and then life put me in this
position of millions of people with this
idolized perception of someone they look
up to is calm cool collected Heather
[__] together see about me so good he's
up there and I was like I really have to
be that now like I better be [__]
perfect now you know my dad was like
that growing up too so I had this like
okay manner stoic and they don't feel
anything and they can they weather the
storm and they're good and I did was
like a very sentient being like
emotional and I was like [__] so I kind
of denied that part of myself for a
while but now being able to just
integrate that and accepting it is who I
am and being able to show it more and
allow it to come up more in situations
like I almost try and twist some
conversations like allow myself to be
like I'm not perfect I have anxiety just
to like show that it's there and then
being like well now this facade's kind
of gone the presentation to be what
people want me to be it's just to be
myself and whatever happens after that
can [__] off so I guess overall the
inner voice in myself I'm building is
just more compassion and empathy I would
say so too I remember
um I did this workout high intensity
interval workout thing on a an assault
bike and
this guy that was coaching me at the
time asked me to
try and remember where my mind went to
where my heart got into zone five yeah
so whatever like 160 170 BPM and above
and the voice this is probably six or
seven years ago and the voice that came
back was [__] awful like it was so
just this sucks you're not good enough
uh Panic uh uh like tightness and and
Terror and I did a workout again a
couple of months ago actually no it was
two weeks ago with Tim Kennedy you know
Tim UFC guy he's like like a
professional bad guy but he works for
the US government anyway uh I did this
workout with him and my heart rate must
have got to that same place and it's the
first time I've done it since then
and the words that came back to me were
so different yeah I couldn't believe it
I was like oh my God I thought that was
the I genuinely thought that was the
physics of my own
uh inner experience
yeah yeah these are just the unchanging
Dynamics these are the laws of the insa
inside of did you respond over time you
had done like you had to work on it and
put in reps and like understand or was
it just purely your physical like
abilities and success in the world
telling you you're good and the podcast
has seen all this [__] was it that or
was it more personal like reflection and
empathy so or both I I think both I I
would love to be able to say you know
just 1500 sessions of meditation and a
couple of good psilocybin trips and you
know that was me sorted
it would be a lie to say that
the world telling you or you proving to
the world and the world saying back
answering back that yes you are good
enough I think it's unrealistic
to have confidence when you don't have
an undeniable stack of proof that you
are who you say you are like if if the
only place that your confidence exists
is in your mind and you've never
manifested it into reality then what
you're asking for isn't confidence it's
delusion yeah because how can you say
that you are all of these things I'm a
really great husband I feel like a great
husband but I go out and cheat on my
wife every night yeah well I there's an
incongruence here but you can behave in
the way of being a great husband and not
believe it yourself because you have
unhealed traumas from the past and stuff
like that so it's definitely both
um but yeah it's it's just really really
important I think for people to hear
that
the answer to the holes and the voids
that you feel inside of yourself
if the guy that's won Mr Olympia four
times in a row is telling you that the
inner work is an important part of that
process and that upon winning the first
one the main sensation was relief the
happiness
what do you where do you think that
you're going to get this from if you're
seeking outside of yourself validation
to fix something that's inside
it's being smart enough to like balance
that too and like know the work you have
to put in so like you have to earn the
right like you said you can't just tell
yourself this delusion you have to earn
the right to get there you have to put
in the work and then you have to kind of
like lean into the okay now I'm really
putting in the work now I need to work
on how why I'm talking to myself so
negatively or not but unless you have
both there it doesn't really work it's
like one plus one equals two but you
can't really do one without the other
what else does it mean to have a
champion mentality to you I know that
you talk about this a lot what are the
principles that you rely on for that
again something that definitely elevated
over time I literally just put that on a
shirt once because it sounded cool and
they're like oh [__] like this there's
more to this and I think the biggest
thing was
originally it was like just winning and
it evolved into just like a no quit
mentality it's accepting these fears I
have this doubts I have this everything
that goes through my mind but regardless
of that not quitting and not giving up
on myself no matter how hard is the time
or what I'm going through and whatever
[__] I feel it's I'm going to still put
in the same work regardless of how I
feel and that's a champion mentality
because Champion thought
controlled by their outside
circumstances they're they control their
own mind inside and how they act and
then the world goes on around them a
huge aspect of that and I'm also now
leaning into I really think like
greatness and champions not only Elevate
themselves but the people around them
and I think it's you are put into a
position where you can help
other your look close people around you
people who follow you people who look up
to you whatever it might be anyone in
your life you're in a position now of
greatness where you can Elevate others
up to a higher level and being able to
inspire them bring them up to be better
people is part of what makes you great
rather than just this selfish Act of
being you being the best for yourself
why is it important to not let anyone
hear you complain I've heard you talk
about this
it's more so
that's a quality that was old quote I
think I've accepted that one a little
bit more but it's more so just not
living in the in the negativity you know
life's gonna get stuck but the more you
focus your perception on it you know the
way you see the world is what the world
is if I choose to be like you know today
sucks I'm tired I don't want to do
cardio I'm [__] two weeks out eating
1500 calories like this sucks that's
what I'm talking about that's all I'm
gonna live in I'm gonna be like
bodybuilding sucks prep sucks why do I
do this but if I'm like this suffering
is literally what's gonna make me great
it's gonna bring me that amazing moment
on stage and all these memories of
everything and this like it's pushing me
to these limits that I know make me feel
proud of myself and all these things if
I focus more on the positive side of
things I'm going to enjoy the reality
regardless of the change the
circumstances can be the exact same but
your perception changes everything about
how you feel about it and I think a lot
of people who are successful or who are
body builders usually kind of tap out
because they make it seem like this
miserable thing oh [__] I have to start
dieting I gotta do cardio and then
you're just like complain thinking about
it and why would you want to do anything
you complain about every day rather than
understanding that's the choice and the
Beautiful things that come from it are
what you should be focusing on and leads
to more
Progressive growth well I mean think
about any Champion that you imagine in
your mind do they complain
like is is a champion the person that
complains yeah no there's a guy called
Josh waitskin he was the guy that the
film seeking Bobby Fisher who's written
about so he's a chess Prodigy at a young
age and he decided to just abscond he
was seen as the new American Phenom
right wonderkid absolute Beast as a
child and he gets basically to the top
of the game of chess and then decides to
leave he goes into Chinese Push Hands
it's like like fighting Tai Chi kind of
gets to the top of that Sport and then
exits again like you can't contact him
on the internet he doesn't have a
website but this guy's a savant and he
did an episode of Tim Ferriss and he was
talking to Tim about the way that him
and his son reframed the weather
and he was saying that a lot of parents
will say to their son or daughter uh we
can't go outside to play today because
it's raining isn't it a shame that we
can't go outside to play because it's
raining which puts all of the Power
outside of the weather correct all of
the power is outside so him him and his
son have worked very hard on saying
things like what a beautiful day it's
raining outside we should go outside and
play in the rain and I think that
there's so much uh wonderful Insight in
that reframe that he's giving yeah it
seems like it's the same definitely yeah
and there's an example I'd already
talked about because it sounds a little
[__] up to say but when I was young I
used to always look at the clock and see
911. I don't know why but I would look
at it and it would say 9 11 and I would
be like [__] like something's bad gonna
happen something and I would worry like
that I'm like and I was a little kid at
the time and I don't know if it was just
like manifesting it but I would like
every day for a while look at the clock
and that would be the time and then when
I was growing up I was like instead of
like constantly living and like thinking
this is bad why don't I switch that that
kid something horrible happened on that
date and I'm like terribly grieving of
all the people and that's horrible but
hang on hang on hang on this was after 9
11. this was the afternoon yeah I
thought you were talking about you were
some premonition oh no I'm not that old
[__] yeah you would have been what like
six when it happened like six yeah yeah
I don't know I thought you were like the
child from the [__] Fifth Element or
whatever it is I wish I actually no I'm
glad I cannot read the future I would
never want that okay yeah yeah yeah but
yeah anyways it was instead of me
fearing the number now every time I see
it I still see it all the time it was
like okay like people died for this but
like our country is still like standing
people are still throwing instead of now
making them death and making ruining my
day why don't I see it as good luck you
know this is like a good luck moment so
for me like I'm on the right path like
people see 11 11. I see this and this
means I'm just moving the right
direction 911 is a good good luck moment
for you if you choose for it to be it's
your perception okay and now I see it
I'm like [__] yeah we're on track let's
go instead of me being like something's
gonna happen I feel better about it and
just reframing your mind you know okay
and I'm not trying to like put anything
positive on what happened because it was
horrible but I know what you mean try
not to [__] up my own minds yeah in
other news this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep it is unbearably hot
in Austin Texas at the moment and I'm
exclusively being kept Alive by my eight
sleep pod Pro cover the Pod Pro cover
actively cools and heats each side of
the bed so if you or your partner sleep
hot or cold it can keep the temperature
absolutely perfect as you progress
through your night's sleep it'll
actively adjust the temperature based on
your sleep stage it tracks your sleep it
tracks your heart rate variability your
resting heart rate how much you're
breathing throughout the night it's
incredible and it does all of this by
just slipping over the top of an
existing mattress that you have good
sleep is the ultimate Game Changer and
if you are focusing on your sleep if you
want to improve your rest and your
recovery this is an awesome place to
begin best of all they deliver
internationally and you can get 150 off
any pod Pro cover by going to
eightsleep.com Modern wisdom that's
e-i-g-h-sleep.com
modern wisdom you mentioned it earlier
on six weeks out from the Olympia you
were on the bathroom floor
crying can you take me through the story
of that day where your mind was at what
life was like at that time and sort of
what the texture of your own existence
was like that led up to that point yeah
for sure
I mean there's part of it I actually
can't touch on that's just too private
but it was Olympia I'd been prepping for
weeks a lot going on in my life
something happened within my family that
was really stressful that I'm not going
to touch on but it was greatly impacting
us going forward and causing a lot of
stress and anxiety in myself and my
whole family and we had just moved to
Florida all this [__] going on still
fears about my health and I had gotten a
sign of my health going wrong with this
inflammation in my shins I get edema and
I started to get that a little bit
thoughtshens factions fat shins
they're not quite giggled but they're
just my shins get fat you know okay so
I'm getting this edema in it all this
personal stuff on the side and it just I
didn't speak about anything it was just
like okay wake up do cardio you know go
to the gym
go to work do this do that just don't
think about it put it down push it down
push and I kept doing that and then I
just I think that with my fiance she was
noticing I was a little bit off and
that's why like having good people
around you [__] everything when you
have like a stressful life she just knew
something with off and she's like are
you good like how are you doing I'm like
I'm good
she asked me again she's like you good
I'm like yeah I'm okay like she's and
then I was like in the bathroom she came
in like are you okay I'm like yeah she
asked me one more time she's like are
you like look at me are you okay and I
just started bawling and I had no idea I
didn't know I was that stressed out I
just was like numb and I just started
bawling like hit the floor it was just
sobbing I was like I just feel like the
world's crashing out on me right now I
feel like all this shit's going on
externally and I'm just trying to focus
on the Olympia I have one two I have to
be better I'm getting so close I feel
behind like all this [__] going on now I
have this business all this chaos going
on in my life and I just like I don't
know if I can handle this and she's just
like yeah [__] yeah like of course you
feel like that like no [__] and she's
like I don't know why like you can share
this with me like the world is on your
shoulders it's [__] stressed out
right now and it should be this is a lot
of opportunity in front of you and if
you want to quit you can but I know you
and I know you won't and right now the
users need to sit in this cry let it out
I'm here with you but I know you're
gonna get out from this you're gonna go
to the gym you're gonna kill your work
you're gonna wake up and you're gonna
keep doing that but this is normal part
of what you're going through this is you
you literally you don't think Michael
Jordan ever broke down and felt like he
couldn't handle the stress that was on
him like building the NBA into what it
was not even just his team I was like
[__] like yeah he didn't talk about it
though and she was like well [__] yeah
then none of them knew no men know how
to talk about their emotions properly
and it was just like it just she just
like built this confidence in me I was
just like [__] yeah of course like this
is a huge pressure there's a lot going
on and I'm stressed what's wrong with
that I'm not gonna let it control me but
I'm allowed to feel this moment right
now and that was just like wow you know
like I can lean on people people are
there to help me I can share how I feel
and someone's gonna actually make me
feel better because my whole life it was
just bottle everything up you can handle
it all by yourself you know you're a man
you can handle this [__] and I was just
like no you know like I'm allowed to
feel but who I am is not going to be
controlled by these feelings so it was
just a huge moment I mean in our
relationship too you know like I'm sure
everyone is with a family alone like I
have stress having to provide for a
family like the ultimate and the men who
feel like they have to provide and like
the world is on their shoulders they
don't understand that like their wife
and their family wants to help them like
they might not make it easier but like
they'll get under that weight with you
and they'll hold that with you and it's
not a burden to them because I always
felt like asking for help would make me
a burden I'd be like I'm just gonna make
someone else's life harder so like
they're stressed out over there I don't
want to add to that I'm just gonna be
okay over here but it actually makes
them feel close to you it makes them it
gives them purpose people want to be
wanted oh my God yeah you got someone
for help they're like [__] yeah like I
feel good about myself today because I
help this person and it really brought
our relationship closer in that moment
it made her feel like I just helped him
in this part where he said he can do it
all by himself all the time and now like
I'm like [__] yeah like I really needed
that and it was a really important
moment for my personal growth Champion
grow relationship growth there's a meme
at the moment of the sort of Lone Wolf
Sigma male guy that's making great
things happen on his own yeah
I'm pretty sure that you are the footage
that's used over the top of a lot of
these Sigma memes in any case yeah could
you do this on your own [__] no
no none of it I couldn't do my YouTube
without Calvin I couldn't have started
my businesses without Maddie I couldn't
be doing raw supplements without Dom and
Matt who are my partners in that I
wouldn't be the man who I am without my
dad I wouldn't be able to have gotten
through my stress as a teenager without
my sister I wouldn't have gone through
the last four Olympics without Courtney
like it's just
like I almost get emotional thinking
about it but when I like reflect back on
like what I'm most grateful for it's
always the people in my life and I'm so
[__] lucky it's like crazy like the
people I have in my life are everything
in the relationships I like build mean
the world to me
I literally like Cry Sometimes by myself
like doing like a gratitude reflection
or something
but it's it's relationships to my life
are everything and I just I know I
wouldn't be where I am without it and I
would never be the one to think I could
do it all by myself
wasn't there a story of your parents
waiting in line to get your autograph
one time they've been to every Olympia
and they go to the athlete meet and
greet and they waited for like an hour
in line or something what the [__]
the [__] mom I'm like we don't want
to bother you we just want a picture I'm
like you're [__] crazy like you're a
VIP you can come backstage you can do
whatever you want here yeah they're just
and that's like that's the humility that
they raise me though you know they never
expect anything and they're just always
quietly there in the background to
support me I wonder whether
part of that humility is maybe where are
you not wanting to lean on other people
comes from
I I do think it's part of it for sure
and I mean my dad is still like my
number one role model but he didn't ask
for help even if he wanted to do
something with me he wouldn't like
building a fence I'd have to be like hey
Dad do you want me to help and he like
loved that but he wouldn't have asked
you know he like all this like no matter
what my family was going through dad was
just like there standing right classes
do the work all of it he had it and I'm
like how the [__] did you do that for so
long have you ever asked him about it I
have and now that I've gotten to this
age I've like gone to him I'm like do
you ever like just feel like [__]
exploding and just like stress and he's
like not really no and I'm like what the
[__] they made him different man they
made him different built different yeah
and he comes from a family that was very
resilient too from a small town you know
working class for other generations and
he's just like you're the beast but I
had to really learn that that's not
normal that's not me and I had to accept
that but it was that's what was
definitely part of the journey so I
think that's definitely
trying to have too much of a
prescription about how you're supposed
to go about things oh well this is the
way that men are supposed to be like on
average there are ways that men and
women are and there are sexed
differences between the two of us and
there are ways that men from Canada and
men from Britain will different etc etc
people from different classes people
that were born at different times
but I think that you're a really good
role model for somebody who has a
particular
programming
and as opposed to trying to retrofit you
into some mold that isn't you when you
did that that was when you found
friction yeah exactly and that was when
there was incongruence and that's when
you weren't able to enjoy things because
you weren't able to fully embody all of
this stuff yeah and also it seems like a
big part of it is finding a partner
who's prepared to see vulnerability as a
strength rather than a weakness for sure
yeah but she's also seen both sides she
seemed like the utmost resilience of
what I've been through and they're like
she's like I don't know she's like
something's gonna happen to you this
year because something happens every
year but it's probably not going to
affect you so like it'll stress you out
but you're still going to win the
Olympia because I know I know you can do
it because I've shown her that proof you
know I've shown her that and now I've
also shown the emotional side and she's
like okay yeah he's gonna [__] break
down and cry in front of me but he's
gonna get up tomorrow and get back to
work so it's like it's at yin and yang
of being able to like complement the
masculine with the feminine and
intertwine and the right balance that
whatever works for you without kind of
holding you back and that's honestly
part of the I mean I could have a
thousand bullet points under Champion
mentality but I used to look up to
people and I still do like Michael
Jordan but that's not [__] me that's
not how I'm Gonna Be A Champion forever
he wanted to kill everyone and [__]
took stuff personally everything with a
battle to the death of being the best
and like I don't feel like that but
that's okay I can still be a champ
there's no rules to being a champion you
know you make the champion makes his own
rules and rides out the wave like that
I like that did you watch the new Arnold
documentary talking about Champions yeah
no wow I mean he's it's very interesting
especially because you'll have seen
Pumping Iron you're gonna guess so um I
probably haven't watched that for about
10 years now but
um reflecting on that era of not only
bodybuilding but America in general it's
so romanticized like it's so
cool I told one of my friends this we
were driving from Austin to Houston to
go to a bachelor party and as I was
going past it's just endless freeways
and huge factories with flags that are
100 feet in the air and the flags 40
feet high and it's slowly waving it's a
pretty you know it's not a country that
I even like I'm from but it's pretty
patriotic I think that's cool but it
made me nostalgic for an era that feels
like it's almost sort of Fallen away and
watching
um the Arnold dock really reminded me of
that sort of unbounded Blue Sky Vision
that everybody had it was pretty [__]
cool but for the people who have seen
the Arnold stuff and are maybe less
familiar with what's happening in your
world of bodybuilding at the moment what
are the differences between Arnold zero
and yours now in classic physique like
physically yeah essentially
I mean obviously you look back at sports
too everything progresses over time we
get more efficient with nutrition with
dieting with Peds with rest with
recovery everything just gets more
efficient and everything excels and you
push limits further and further so now I
mean
open bodybuilding is just you look at it
and you don't even question that they're
even the same classes no limitations no
weight limits dude they're on stage at
300 pounds like three percent body fat
just [__] monsters like huge stuff
you can't even fathom like when I see
them in person so I'm like wow that's a
real person which is insane but back in
back in the arrow days it was purely
like it was bigger upper bodies legs
weren't massive you weren't shredded it
was more about being full and round and
just like aesthetic and which is what
classic physique was brought in for but
even still the contrast classic physique
versus like the Arnold era it's way
leaner now it's still it's getting to
just as lean as the open bodybuilders
it's like shredded glutes you know your
ass is just striated at the end of the
day feathered quads just looks like you
have no body fat on you and probably
probably about the same way I think
Arnold was 240 on stage approximately
and my weight cap is 240 I'm about 239
when I weigh in so we're about the same
weight just like now it's required to be
a lot less body fat
so if you put
uh Arnold and serge nubrey uh on stage
now they would look
aesthetically pleasing but their
condition would be significantly
different to the guys that are up there
now yeah it would be yeah it wouldn't be
the same
but what would be interesting is if you
could put Arnold to be born in 1990 and
then come up in this time those genetics
and those with all the stuff now what
would he look like Sergio Bray would be
even bigger freak Arnold's a goat
because he did it first but I think
Sergeant Bray would be like insane to
see in our generation
is there a part of you that
wishes obviously you'd have to the
family would have to come back and the
misses and all of that stuff but is
there a part of you that wishes that you
could have had a crack during the Golden
Era as well
no I've never really thought of that
honestly I really think this era right
now just perfectly like where I'm meant
to be and obviously it's been working
out pretty [__] great so far so I
don't temptate with that I'm just
grateful for where I'm at
I read a story that you bought an
inversion table
is this true I did but it came in it
came with a 100 like page pamphlet and
like 500 like instructions to put it
together and I never put it together
right so there's a story that says you
bought an inversion table so that you
could make yourself a quarter of an inch
taller so that you could get an extra 10
pounds weight limit in your category I
tried yeah I did but I didn't put it
together I went to a chiropractor
consistently and they have a machine
pictures
is that not just the medieval rack is
that not a torture thing you've got a
peasant with one of those floppy caps on
yeah
we'll get you one inch taller literally
yeah it looks more like Frankenstein you
like sit in this machine like upright
and then it tilts you down and they have
a thing around your waist that just
pulls your spine right and I did that
for a while but I'm like I'm just over
six one so I'd have to agree in a full
inch to be over six two so I'm like I
would never do it but I also don't want
to shrink so I I've definitely tried a
few things I hang from bars all the time
too elongate my spine it's also just
good for your spine but yes classic
physique is just a battle to be taller
essentially to make your weight
I've seen a bunch of rumors on the
internet saying that if the timing was
right you would roll straight from a
classic physique show potentially into
an open show
definitely thought about it yeah have
you really I have but there's no open
show with after the Olympia there's like
one in Japan but I would want to do like
a decent show I'd rather Stack Up Beside
like a top 10 Olympian and see like how
do you think you'd get on
it depends on the show if you were to
put me in the Olympia
if you put me in Olympia the way I look
in classic right now I don't think I
would do top I would hit the top ten but
I think if I was able to like be a
little bit less leaner and Fuller and
like I always have to die down about
five pounds of muscle just to make my
weight so if I were able to be like full
as [__] like sometimes I'm like checking
pictures when I'm four weeks out I have
a high carb day I'm like I'm gonna open
bodybuilder right now this is crazy I
would love to just see what this looks
like on stage I think I could be like
top
give me a year and I think I could be
top 15 in like Olympia but there's no
there's no part of you that's like I
should give that a crack
no more than just that like this banter
like yeah I just really truly like I
love classic physique and I love what it
like pushes what it inspires people to
be more so than like when I was young I
literally was about to quit bodybuilding
in 2016 because there I turned Pro and I
was like I have there have to be 300
pounds or go down to men's physique and
I wasn't wearing board shorts and I
wasn't getting a 300 pounds so I was
gonna retire but then literally that
year classic physique came out and I was
like this is for me I'll give it a shot
and then it just ran with it
yeah it seems so perfect in terms of the
timing for you in terms of being able to
find a sport that you actually enjoyed
that wasn't going to make you go too
freaky so what would you need to do
let's say that you did go across to open
what would you have to do to your
Physique in order to be able to
uh improve
a lot of it would be so right now I give
my body a lot of rest after the Olympia
I could be once a year and I take like
three months off the Olympia and then
coming back it's just like relearning
proper training patterns perfecting my
form like making sure I'm healthy and so
if I were to really want to do the open
I'd have to like take like a week off
the rest and then get back to work hold
all that weight and just start growing
for a full eight month and I don't push
food hard right now I go like I'll cycle
my calories if I start to get too fat
I'm like oh I don't pull it back down I
would just have to like lead into the
fat put on a little chill I wouldn't be
like fat fat but I like being lean
consistently lean enough so I feel good
I have to put on a lot of weight and
just eat consistently my training would
be the exact same it would be mainly
food a little bit more PDS of course but
just kind of dabbling around that I
think I could do it with just food
though
that would be [__] great man it's
such a shame that you can't do that
there's um
the 100 mile record for endurance racing
running and the 24 hour record for a
while when it was still a relatively new
title were often broken together yeah
because I think it takes
I might be wrong let's say it takes like
uh
14 hours or 12 hours or something to get
100 and then people would just continue
that pace or try and continue that pace
here and break the 24 Zach bitter this
guy from Austin did it he broke both
records in one it'd be so [__] cool
for somebody to like break through one
and then go and go to the next place at
a really great show I don't even think
like like I said if they let me do both
on the same day it wouldn't be good
because I'm too sucked down so I think I
would look pretty small up there what
body fat do you step on stage at you got
any idea you ever been in a dexa I
haven't no I don't even try and guess
because everyone on the internet's like
oh Ronnie Coleman came out and said he
was like zero percent or something and
people were like I don't think that's
possible if I had to guess I think it
would be like four I think it was just
[__] around but people took it
seriously but I think I would be around
four or five if I had to like be
conservative
and to get into the open category you'd
have to you would be able to lose a tiny
bit of condition yeah a little bit Yeah
my like because my structure it would
kind of make up for my conditioning I
think we'll get back to talking to Chris
in one minute but first I need to tell
you about element
I'm gonna look there you're gonna throw
it and I'm just gonna catch it because
I'm a I'm in I'm epic right we'll get
back to talking to Chris in one minute
but first I need to tell you about
element element is a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium with no gluten no coloring
no artificial ingredients or any other
BS it is the way that I've started my
morning every single day for over three
years now video guy Dean uses it and it
is an awesome beautiful very enjoyable
drink proper hydration plays a critical
role in reducing muscle cramps and
fatigue whilst optimizing brain health
and regulating appetite best of all
they've got a no BS no questions asked
refund policy with unlimited duration so
you can buy it and if you do not like it
for any reason you can get your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you love it head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with any purchase
that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom
talk to me about your morning routine
what does that look like typically
it depends on the time of year really
okay so let's say off season and prep
off-season I wake up and I usually just
do a bit of light cardio what sort of
time do you typically get up
it's been brutal lately I've been in
different time zones for the last six
months so it's just whatever time zone
I'm on okay but lately I've just been
not putting on alarm and I've been
waking up at about 7 30 8 o'clock or so
lately and I normally wake up and I just
do like a little bit of cardio just like
20 minutes just to make sure my
appetite's gone and then I have a cold
plunge I usually dip my legs in there at
least if not my full body and just like
are up to my waist then shower eat go to
work what will you tend to have off
season what will breakfast look like
again it varies consistently I get sick
of food really quick especially
breakfast foods so I usually don't like
eating eggs when I'm eating a lot of
food so I normally just make a smoothie
and then I'll have like oatmeal like
blended into the smoothie and some like
Ezekiel bread toast and almond butter
okay and then what about prep which I'm
guessing is significantly more dialed
prep evolves and like I just I'm not
trying to like I evolve so I'm very
fluid like my routines are like what
time do you train depends on the time of
year like it's just wherever I feel
natural I just kind of flow into that
state and do what I can and I kind of
thrive in that structure rather than
really regimented but in prep
I'll wake up in the morning and I
usually will like do like a breath work
thing because I get sucked in that and
it's not even for like At first I tried
to do it for like mental to like kind of
like tap deep into my mind and now it's
just literally to oxygenate my body
before like waking up doing cardio
because I realized if I did a little bit
of breath work and like just like you
know like Wim hofstyle like three rounds
of 30 breaths and hold an exhale repeat
three rounds in the morning and then I
went and did cardio I didn't need
caffeine I was wide awake and I could
like Blaster my cardio way easier and I
just felt way better wow and then after
that I'll usually sauna or cold tub and
combine it I'll always cold up if I
sauna because I like finishing with cold
and then
cardio will be higher at that point and
then I'll go shower and eat and the goal
that I do in the mornings it's nothing
crazy like it's just simple as that but
I usually try and put my phone on
airplane mode when I go to bed and not
look at it until the shit's done yeah
that's such a hack do you sleep well if
it's on airplane mode it doesn't matter
but I'm gonna guess you sleep with your
phone outside of your bedroom as well
um and I still usually keep it I usually
have an alarm still or I just have it in
the corner of the room and it's on the
airplane mode but I just don't it's
basically a break until yeah it gets
turned off yeah are you not concerned at
all there's a lot of talk on the
internet about reducing inflammation
through using cold plunge when you're
trying to maximize hypertrophy is this
something that you're not particularly
worried about
I think there's a lot of and again I'm
not the Science Guy but I've looked into
it too and I never started doing it for
purely recovery and hypertrophy I
started doing it because of my
autoimmune and just overall systemic
inflammation and health and I just knew
that it would be better for me to reduce
my inflammation
and so I what I looked into was it was
saying that immediately after a workout
when you're getting that like high
inflammation response which is we're
sending blood and nutrients to the
muscle to recover that's when you want
to avoid it so typically if I do like a
long like a 10 minute session that's on
my rest day but if I'm just doing it in
the morning I do it in the morning and
then I don't work out till later in the
day and I don't do it after I work out
so I have a full two meals go to sleep
wake up in the morning and I'll do it
then and it hasn't affected me at all if
anything it's it's helped my joints from
being overly inflamed so I can
continually train and push myself so if
I lose like two percent hypertrophy but
my joints feel better to train harder to
me the outcome is just worth it it's a
trade-off yeah yeah what about walks and
stuff like cardio yeah continuing to
just get yourself moving sunlight
exposure stuff like that yeah I think
like do I do it or do the real I
definitely do more in prep again I
definitely slack off more than I should
in my off season but I do cardio my off
season so that I can eat I usually just
do a treadmill in there but when I'm in
prep I'll just like roam around outside
a little bit after a meal just to make
sure adjusting properly and also to take
my mind off life sometimes and just kind
of relax but I'm not too like crazy
methodical with these things I just make
sure everything's on point and then if
my digestion ever goes to [__] that's
when I start manipulating things but I'm
super consistent with my food so
normally my digestion is pretty good
tell you what's crazy have you ever worn
a glucose monitor one of those things on
the back of your arm if you ever do that
and it doesn't even need to be a
particularly high carb meal but if you
spike your glucose and then go on a walk
the difference is unbelievable really
yeah yeah it just seems to mediate
insulin sensitivity so well yeah
um and there's also muscles I think that
cross basically across your stomach that
when you walk that sort of contralateral
movement that actually helps uh
digestion okay so yeah walks after um
after food Stu McGill the back pain
specialist is one guy that gave me that
forever and ever and ever ago and uh
yeah trying to do that that's one
advantage of living near a park you know
or being in a house
it's hard in Florida though yeah it'll
be like 110 degrees in humid so if I'm
in the office I go take a walk outside
and come back trench and sweat yeah true
it might be good for the uh for the
calorie burn but that's one thing I was
I was talking to a couple of friends
about that moved into this awesome new
apartment complex one of the things that
you don't see is a price that you pay is
if you do want to go out for a walk it's
like five minutes yeah it's five minutes
to get downstairs well if you take the
stairs that could be part of your walk
uh yeah this has a kind of lame though
aren't they they're kind of tough yeah
but going downstairs is at least good
for your knees so true what are you
doing for knee Health are you into the
knees over toes stuff at all have you
got into this I I've dabbled in that
I've dabbled I downloaded the app for my
dad because he has any issues and then I
don't think he used it so I just started
using it myself and I just took some
things that like I found I could put
into my routine super easily like
walking backwards with a weight and when
I don't have like a sled I'll do it on
the treadmill turned off yep I'll just
turn off the treadmill and push the
tread I'll warm up like that I go on the
stairs walk up it turn around walk
backwards and some videos
yeah I trained my like tibia rather than
just my calves too some banned stuff
pushing my knee backwards I've
definitely implemented that and it seems
to be helping okay so if you only had 10
exercises for the rest of time yeah
that's all you have in your library to
stay as muscular as possible
give me the list so the the goal is to
be as muscular as possible correct if I
were let's say I'm competing and I have
10 exercises sure
all right [__] sorry I'm gonna have to
count it on my hands
um squats why
just overall leg growth they help glutes
quads like a large portion of the legs
barbell back squats okay simple if it's
my whole life I might actually do some
miss machine squats
because I'll help my knees in a little
bit be a little bit easier okay
possibility and people hate me for that
but I love squatting the Smith machine
all right I get a lot of [__] for that
um deadlifts just to get something
that'll Target the my hamstrings and so
I don't have to take out another 10 of
two something too hamstring focused and
glute and back focus
um Pull-Ups so I can hit my back and
biceps in one overhand underhand
neutral
incline dumbbell press uh-huh I find
inclines a little bit better on your
shoulders so if you're doing it's the
only I said you can do you won't [__] up
your shoulders as much then dumbbell
it'll just keep you a little bit more
symmetrical yeah I love that I've always
loved that exercise which is weird
because uh incline barbell press is one
of the most uncomfortable for my
shoulders really yeah yeah most people
feel better with dumbbell because you
can go in a position around a little bit
for you yeah okay how many is that
that's four that's four yeah six left
this is gonna be hard without like but
I'd like have to make a list of 20 and
cut out but um the autism is put to one
side for now yeah we're doing this in
our heads together
um
dumbbell shoulder press uh-huh seated
seated you have no shoulder press yeah I
think that'll help your triceps and
shoulders a lot
um
maybe a a close grip flat bench
different part of the chest and triceps
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
four left
dumbbell curl just something
specifically I'm so glad how do you want
to live without you dumbbells physique I
just need it for my mind exactly yeah
with that are you uh supinated again
this is the only one that you're gonna
get he's seated he's standing uh uh
standing supinated okay good good the
the OG of dumbbell curls yeah and it's
gonna be one of them at the time it
can't be both arms together it's gonna
be one on one at a time yeah good
Netflix in the basics good stuff
um I think you've got three left yeah
three left I think what parts of the
body I'm missing right now calves
probably
oh [__] yeah the castle there are you
talking
but you're not gonna get it with
anything else
a little bit on a deadlift but
maybe I'll just do stairs on the side
and I'll tell you but okay fine you've
still got three exercises you only
needed seven so far ah there they say
bent over row no that's over row okay
it'll that'll help like stability the
core as well uh-huh and then like lower
back and obviously upper back yeah
because the only back exercise that
you've had so far is the pull-up
deadlifts and pull-ups yeah bent over
rows yeah okay yeah yeah um so I got two
left yeah
probably like a hanging leg raise just
to make sure your core is getting hit
you're not like
[__] up your back and then
this is a tough one I think I'm trying
to like focus on either lateral raises
or like overhead tricep extension
because I haven't had a lot of like
specific triceps I would probably do
lateral raises just to get some meaty
delts over [__] yeah you've got the
close grip and you've got the uh incline
press yeah it's so interesting so Ryan
Terry who I know that you've trained
with before I asked him the same
question and his ab exercise as well was
hanging libraries yeah it seems to be
the industry Insider
I always try and work on my lower abs
because it's harder for me to contract
with rather than upper and that's
usually when your stomach hangs out and
on bodybuilding stage you don't want
your like gut hanging out essentially
what pulls it in is the lower part when
you do a hanging leg rest or like lying
leg raise it hits that part more and
also like hanging from a bar is really
good for your shoulders and spine so
you're kind of hitting two birds with
one stone one of my friends Alex who
basically has an unlimited budget said
that he'd been to every shoulder
specialist on the planet it's like I've
spoken to every single person all of the
most expensive specialists in the world
the best thing that I've found is
hanging from a Pokemon yeah
yeah it's wild uh I think he does it
I think he ends up like um strapping up
uh and just hanging from there for about
90 seconds a couple of times a day
I'd heard a rumor I don't know whether
you'd heard this that because we'd spent
so much time as uh primates swinging
through the trees that the way that our
shoulder still articulates like that
position yeah is still one that's very
comfortable to us and I would I'm going
to get torn apart by people who
understand biomechanics in in the
comments but
um there's supposed to be a little bit
of Truth to that and it definitely feels
nice for sure I mean even if you're
standing in a doorway and you just like
do this you're just chilling like you
just feel better what about your future
CrossFit career so we've spoken about
what you've done what you've done so far
but before we started you've said that
you want to take up CrossFit once you
finish yeah I mean I just I used to be
very athletic when I was young is really
what got me into bodybuilding I just
loved Sports I played like six of them
when I was younger and I would like to
get back to that like form of feeling
like I can run I'm strong I can do a lot
of body weight exercises I could train
anywhere in the world and just kind of
like challenging my body in a new way
because I'm obviously not going to be
hitting any PRS in the gym or being
heavier than I've ever been than I am in
my Peak bodybuilding career so just
finding a new to focus on my dabble in
that but it's more of like an athletic
training that like you can call Crossfit
okay it's um
it's so funny to think that
the particular sport that you chose to
go after actually has a load of
restrictions on it like it's very very
consistent very repetitive by its nature
not a team sport you know there's a
bunch of different things that it
constrains you from doing you know what
do you weigh now how heavy are you about
262 right now 260. right you said you
could dunk a year ago though like 260. I
got a video of it so I'm not lying no
way do you put it online it is online
yeah [__] yeah uh but yeah my point
being that a game of pickup you know 30
minute game of pick at basketball
probably be not very good for your knees
no I I did it last year I was telling
you that yeah yeah I wouldn't play with
a bunch of the guys here we played
probably played for almost an hour it
was pretty long and I could not walk for
a week like it was just inflammation and
pain I was just sitting so bizarre right
because you think
athlete professional athlete what do you
do for a living I I like Fitness things
yeah so people often don't call
bodybuilders athletes yeah but like it's
not that Fitness yeah yeah and you also
said that after your last crossfit
workout you'd had a cough for like 10
days yeah there's a
camera what they call it the specific
person they named the car yeah yeah did
you do friend is that the workout I
don't think so okay but you got Franklin
from like a really gentle workout yeah
no not that bad yeah it's
thinking about what people want to do
once they retire so to speak yeah
um
and the fact that you've had all of
these different physical Outlets that
have been like I can't do that and I
better not do that and snowboarding I
can only go twice a year in case what if
I rupture an ACL that's not going to be
very good yeah yeah so you are very much
constrained with this in other news this
episode is brought to you by a product
I've used every single day for over
three years now and that is ag1 it's a
foundational nutrition supplement that
covers whole body Health helps with my
digestion it helps with my energy it is
the staple to my supplement regime and
it's the same for Dr Andrew Hume and Joe
Rogan Lex Friedman Tim Ferriss all of
them have been using it for a very long
time and that's because they invest in
the highest quality ingredients and
they've upgraded the recipe 52 times
over the last decade as new researchers
come in also there is a 90-day
money-back guarantee so you can buy it
and try it for 89 days and if you do not
like it they will give you your money
back if you're looking for a simpler
effective investment for your health try
ag1 get five free ag1 travel packs play
a year Supply vitamin D and that 90-day
money-back guarantee by going to
drinkag1.com
wisdom that's drink ag1.com
wisdom when it comes to your training
what's with the no shoes thing
it's just part of a I mean there's a
movement online honestly but I just
discovered it by accident I wore
Converse my whole life up until I was
like 20 years old and I started to get
bunions on my foot where like my toes
were just like angled way far out to
like outwards and then my the side of my
foot started to really hurt and I was
also getting really bad knee pain and I
was like what the [__] was wrong with my
feet and I realized my feet don't fit in
Converse I have really wide feet I'm a
size 13 like e like super wide and I'm
wearing the most narrow shoe you could
fathom so I decided to start taking it
off and training Barefoot I started
rocking like socks and Birkenstocks
which people used to roast me for but
now it's in style so not cool now but
working on the gym it just felt better
it's like I was doing like toe exercises
where I would spread my toes I was
wearing toe spacers and then just the
gym was just a place where I didn't have
to wear shoes so I could like train in
socks and I just felt better and over
time I didn't do a whole lot of other
things a few other things but my knees
just started to feel better my squats
started to feel a little bit more
natural yeah have I seen
footage of you walking on your treadmill
in the morning in barefoot shoes as well
yeah yeah I've ordered I've had like
I've had vivos Lambs zero
and maybe one other but I've tried
what's your favorite what have you
finished on I'm between the zeros and
lamps lamps are more comfortable if
you're wearing if you're barefoot in
them or if you're not wearing socks
which I I feel like is the point of it
so I always Barefoot yeah people are
getting into this man Mark Bell's power
project and seamer and all of those guys
when I went down there everybody was in
either Barefoot or some crazy just sucks
because they're so ugly yeah I'm a big
shoe guy I have like a whole collection
but I'm just like [__] these things are
they're all like plastic and black and
just like at least make a nice one you
know no one no one has yet there's an
open market for that right now how do
you prioritize recovery and rest in your
program what is it that you're focusing
on for the biggest winners I mean
there's a huge Avenue but sleep is
probably like the number one thing and
in one of their brain health aging or
just like high performance sleep is like
one of the most important aspects anyone
can have you lose any bit of sleep then
you're used to and your body just
suffers more than you can even like
understand so I think being super
regimented on sleep and that's why like
when I'm in different time zones I'm
like I'm not set an alarm some people
believe you should create your circadian
rhythm as fast as possible I'm like no
I'm just gonna get eight hours no matter
what like I'm tired I'm just gonna sleep
so I let myself just get at least eight
hours of sleep and I usually aim for
nine because I don't sleep through the
whole night fully but I think sleep has
been absolutely huge and honestly at a
point in my career when I was 21 and I
started to get a bit more injuries and
just like starting to feel like adrenal
fatigue almost I was like I was trained
like six seven days a week for like
three hours I was like I feel like I
need to tone this back a bit and then I
started training five days a week for
three hours and then I realized I had a
little bit more progress and then a year
later I was like that was catching up to
me so I'm like okay what if I train like
three days on one day off but I'm only
in the gym for like an hour and a half
or two Max two hours including warm-up
and stuff and I just noticed as I was
pulling away from that kind of like
volume essentially I actually started to
progress more and feel better I started
to feel like I was like going the
reverse way of Aging so I'll allowing
myself to have more time to recover
actually made me stronger which I don't
even when I say that I try and like
preemphasize if you're 19 years old
don't listen to me
enjoy this time right now go deadlift
[__] max out every day and just like
seep in these moments because they will
be gone yes but read your body when you
start to feel a little tired make sure
you're taking time off and then
obviously basic [__] like
protein intake is obviously huge timing
of it I really don't think matters I
think she at least four four meals in a
day so you're spreading it out but
whenever you get in it's fine ice bath
sauna has helped me a lot I do believe
that stretching active recovery like
doing cardio and stretching midi lay
after so you're a little bit warm and
then I do a lot of soft tissue work so
when I'm in prep I do probably a week or
two and that's something where you got
to make sure you find someone who
actually understands the body who's good
at it and it's not bad not that you have
to go to someone who's going to make it
miserable like you're crying the whole
time but they have to at least like have
know what they're doing and it should
hurt a little bit they thought they
shouldn't just be trying to hurt you but
you need to find someone good because
I've been through like 10 in my career
and I finally just found one now showed
Dr Marlin my boy down here in Florida
he's a chiropractor who does massage for
me and he's he's just so smart he just
crushes it and this has helped me a lot
one of my friends was pushed so hard
during a workout that he ended up
getting a like a blood blister below his
eye from the pain from like holding it
in and trying not to screw
that's like the ego of the massage
therapist just trying to hurt you I
think it was his ego as well that was
like you're not gonna make me make any
noise if you hold it in it's like trying
to trying to squeeze out a really big
poo yeah
have I seen you in a altitude chamber no
no I've done cry or maybe if you've seen
something but I haven't I've
that's the next step though Hyperbaric
as well I'm like I need one of those in
my house I think slept in one of those
when I told you about those stem cells
in Columbia yeah have you been in one
before at all no so the weird thing is
let's say that you want to do an hour
session it takes you about 15 or 20
minutes to go down right so they've got
to pump the pressure in yeah and then
like we're up to 14 PSI 15 16 17 and
you're watching this number go up so
it's like being in a rapidly climbing
airplane
every five seconds oh so you're
permanently yawning for like
maybe I should over and over and over
and over again and then if you want to
get out it's like that's another 15 or
20 minutes because they've got to bring
you back down because if they just
opened it I don't know what you'd
probably just get like Rippling from
limo yeah I don't know I don't want to
think about what would happen
um
yeah he's I don't know I can't really
work out well I did two sessions of it
for an hour I feel like you gotta do it
like a lot yeah I love a lot uh Bill
Perkins one of my friends from uh Austin
was talking about how he'd read this
Finnish study and if people went and did
three accumulated three hours of
altitude chamber stuff per week that
this thing happened to their telomere
length and it reduced aging and all this
stuff but he realized that the closest
facility that he could find was like
three and a half hours away yeah so he
was wasting like four and a half hours
of his life three times a week to try
and save a little bit of time so I'm
just gonna die sooner all of the time
precisely precisely so it's such a false
economy when it comes to that
what about uh bad habits so we've spoken
about all of the things that you try and
get done yeah what are the things that
you think hold you back or if you were
able to get rid of them uh your quality
of life would improve or you would be a
better athlete or a better person
um
I mean this year was the ability to say
no something that was a lot of
opportunity coming my way just I said
yes to way too many things and I
traveled like every week for like
almost four months I think and I was
barely home and I didn't even understand
that how much it was impacting me until
I would get in the end and I was just
like on edge stressed out like didn't
feel good felt like I'm behind on my
training where I should be you know just
like snapping just didn't feel good and
I'm just like I felt like I had to do
these things like I'm a business owner
now rather than just like a sponsored by
someone so like I feel like required to
go to these events I had already
pre-planned these like other seminars
I've done or meet greets in Europe and
like different countries and meeting
manufacturers in India and like all over
the place and last year I was always
like no travel I gotta focus and this
year I'm just like saying yes to
everything because I felt like I had to
and I was like no you do not [__]
have to do that [__] like I'm never
doing that again so one thing is
definitely just speak like being able to
speak up more for myself and be like no
I'm not doing that no matter how much I
get pushed to do it because I just a lot
of the time you're being pushed by
yourself right often yeah exactly no
it's like there's some external person
saying Chris you need to go and do the
whatever thing it's your own drive your
own desire
like we were talking about like the the
chasing of more and more success but
you're sacrificing your current life to
have more success but even though you're
less happy with the way you're actually
living your life like what's actually
the point of that like this is the most
amazing time of my life and I'm just
trying to like run through it and be
busy all the time and not sit down and
enjoy it or do I want to step back and
maybe have less potential business
success but 98 of it still but also be
more enjoying of this time of my youth
than in the middle of like my golden
years it's such an important story have
you heard about the the parable of the
Mexican fishermen have you heard this no
uh so it's it's a really cool story
about someone see if I can find it about
somebody who is I can indeed parable of
the Mexican fishermen an American
investment banker was at the peer of a
small coastal Mexican Village when a
small boat with just one fisherman
docked inside the small boat with
several large yellow fin tuna the
American complimented the Mexican on the
quality of his fish and asked how long
it took to catch them the Mexican
replied only a little while the American
asked why he didn't stay out longer and
catch more fish the Mexican said he had
enough to support his family's immediate
needs the American then asked but what
do you do with the rest of your time the
Mexican fisherman said I sleep late fish
a little play with my children take
siestas with my wife Maria and stroll
into the village each evening where I
sip whine and play guitar with my Amigos
I have a full and busy life the American
scoffed I have an MBA from Harvard and
can help you you said you should spend
more time fishing with the proceeds by a
bigger boat with the proceeds from the
bigger boat you could buy several boats
and eventually you would have a fleet of
fishing boats instead of selling your
catch to a middleman you could sell
directly to the processor eventually
opening up your own Cannery you could
control the product processing and
distribution he said of course you need
to leave this small coastal fishing
Village and move to Mexico City then Los
Angeles and eventually to New York where
you would run your expanding Enterprise
the Mexican fisherman asked but how long
will all of this take to which the
American replied oh 15 to 20 years or so
but then what as the Mexican the
American laughed and said well that's
the best part when the time was right
you would announce an IPO sell your
company stock to the public and become
very rich you would make millions
millions then what the Americans said
then you could retire move to a small
coastal fishing village where you could
sleep late fish a little play with your
kids take siestas with your wife and
stroll to the village in the evening
where you could sip wine and play guitar
with your Amigos life is often simpler
than we make it yeah
so good so good yeah that's so accurate
definitely something I've been that's
exactly what I felt this year putting
more on my plate like and I'm in that
like prime time right now especially as
like a
part influencer business owner
competitor all this stuff going on I'm
like this is the time to stack it all on
Top This is my time to do all this but
this is also like the most exciting time
of my life to enjoy where I'm actually
at yeah so like like to be the strongest
I am in the gym which is something I
[__] love to do so why would I take
away from that and just like create more
stress and pressure on myself when I can
just be here just to have more in the
future which I already have enough that
I need so that's a great story for sure
I know that you're quite health
conscious about bodybuilding yeah but
obviously it's a very rough sport
physically psychologically hormonally do
you have any concerns about longevity
you know you've done an awful lot of
like extreme things to your body over
the last decade how worried are you
about that longer term I mean I think if
you're a bodybuilder you don't worry
about that you're either stupid or lying
to be completely honest so it's
something I definitely obviously with
all my own health conditions from the
past on the Forefront of my brain but I
just manage it as best as I can you know
there's blood work you can get done
consistently to keep your markers on
there's a lot of tests you know
Diagnostics now are absolutely insane
and if you want to stay healthy long
term it's getting something if
something's going on with you catching
it early so I do a lot of Diagnostics
and blood work and make sure I'm getting
healthy and ever since I was sick in
2018 my blood Works kind of continuously
improved so I know there's no like
negative impact I'm putting on myself
like I've reduced a lot of the stress
and negative things I put in my body and
increase more of my health like the type
of food I give in me it's not just
calories it's actually the the quality
of the food and the type of food and
everything that I need that like I
really focus on rather than just
straight macros I've never been a macro
guy and I'm even less now because I
actually care about my health and all
these aspects like everything I know I
need with my body comes from a lot of
the Diagnostics I've done and vitamins
and all this stuff and I just know that
I've made an agreement with myself that
when these things start to falter and
they start to go down no matter where
I'm at my career if I'm peaked if I'm
not peaked if I'm about to be better I
just need to call it I really I know
that it's not worth it to me you know
there's a life after bodybuilding for
sure who I am is not a bodybuilder
there's more to me than that I'll be
happy without it and there's no point in
like
the beautiful this moment in my life is
it's already been a great time but if
I'm going to sacrifice my future life
hopefully with a family and my children
of my own I'm going to be sick or unable
to enjoy it with them that's the biggest
thing I would regret so I just I'm
staying on top of knowing where I'm at
and if it goes down I just kind of have
to call it quits yeah I've heard you say
that in the past there was compounds and
things that you would have taken that
now you're like this is true yeah it's
too dangerous what are the things that
for you are like off the table with
regards to this is too much this is too
risky for me the biggest one is like
tread yeah the good old Trend that like
there's guys who literally like base
their social media off that now it's
just like a meme of the internet of the
gym culture and I don't even think
people realize the impact that these
jokes and memes have on like people
coming up who just see you constantly
joking and talking about saying you need
more of it to like be better and feel
stronger and all this [__] but
that's probably the most toxic thing you
can put in your body and I've done it in
the past but I don't anymore I just
haven't touched it in like five years
why just the toxicity it causes in your
body like it just comes in it harms your
kidneys your liver just everything that
takes your body to process it and go
through it it's just not natural it's
not meant to be in your body and it
makes you strong as [__] and people if
you say they feel like they're on top of
the world when they take it but to me
that's not really worth the health risk
anymore and another reason why I love
classic physique is because I had a
weight cap and I was close to my weight
cap like three years ago not at it but I
could have taken more [__] and really
tapped out and been at the point where I
couldn't put on any more weight or I
could actually take less [__] and forth
myself to work harder be more consistent
with my diet and my training and my
recovery and then still get that result
but it would just be a little bit more
effort you know there's a peak body a
Peak open bodybuilder with no weight cap
probably needs to do everything don't be
the best but if I can just still put in
discipline in the work and then take out
some of the less [__] that's iron on my
body then I'm on the same point that I
would be it's just a little bit more
effort it says it all that you as
somebody who is competing at the highest
standard of bodybuilding on the planet
is still finding
compounds where you're like that's off
the table yeah that's too much for sure
you can always find
things to take out and things to add in
and ways to get better things that are
like unnecessary and just kind of
fine-tuning and you know like a lot of I
mean a lot of any type of success is
getting the most out of the least and
what other effort the amount of work you
put in in a day the amount of [__] you
put in your body the amount of training
even you do it's just being as efficient
as possible so that you're putting in
you're getting maximum result from
minimum effort essentially yeah we've
spoken before and I think that it's a
smart approach that you have of not
talking about the things that you use
and dosages because it's just going to
result in people doing if I take X then
equals Chris bumps precisely exactly
um
but I I think that you've mentioned
before people would be very surprised at
how low those numbers are I think most
people in the sport can look at me and
be like okay he hasn't made my changes
in six years like and he they see me
training and they see how consistent I
am so they would understand but I think
a lot of maybe aspiring kids who like
who just want to like maybe look like me
or look like a pro bodybuilder they'd be
like no I gotta take this but he's lying
like I got I need more like to be like
that why don't I look like that and they
don't see a my amazing genetics shout
out to my parents for that and then B
the 10 years of work I put in that has
been consistent you know what is the
ratio of attention that you get from
guys versus girls
oh like 90 10.
in favor of men of course literally and
I think my Instagram statistics are like
91 men
yeah anyone who thinks that this life is
Gonna Get You girls what does it say
that like the king of the Aesthetics bro
era is just swimming in men yeah like
there's just men everywhere and all of
these guys that think I'm gonna go to
the gym and I'm gonna if I get buffed
then I'm gonna get loads of attention
with the girls inside which also there's
there's a line of respect in that
because let's say you start doing
something for the attention of women and
then in the end you don't get it but you
realize how much you love it so you see
keep doing it and your brothers are like
that's dope and like you're not doing it
so your Bros love you but you're doing
it now because you actually love to do
it rather than just getting a girl you
know yeah well there's like a little bit
more meaning in doing it for yourself
and just because you love training come
for the girls stay for the games exactly
it yeah yeah but it's dude it's just so
funny like every person that I've spoken
to that's in that's got a big platform
that is built around the physique it's
like
it's a lot of men every time a lot of
men out there that like are you getting
requests for sock they said please send
me your used socks please I'm used to
but I don't I don't read my DMs anymore
okay I don't really go through Calvin's
job no poor guy I'm the only one logged
into my stuff he sent me the stuff I
post it okay but I just don't even dive
into it there's too much [__] in there
there's gonna be it's a cesspool down
there Chris there's all these like
groups now and it's just like memes and
tags and like there's not even like
anyone actually saying anything what do
you mean like people will start a group
yep with like all their boys and then
like lifting club and it will be you and
your friends from high school and then
there's Strokers mom said in there
because it's funny maybe you'll see it
one day and I have like hundreds of
those and that's all I really and
they're not even messaging me they're
messing each other and I'm just in the
chat
so I'll like I have like every couple
months I'll go and I'm like bored
waiting someone I like look and I'm like
nope
there's just nothing in there yeah [__]
yeah what um
talking about social media in the social
media game something that you guys like
pay attention to uh to continue to build
how have you dealt with the increasing
amount of
notoriety and and pressure and eyes on
you and stuff as somebody that's pretty
heavily introverted and yeah once
they're privacy you've had to make
public relationship with Mrs business
you know the most stressful times of
your sporting career and stuff as well
yeah
how does that feel like have you
struggled with that and how's it helped
you to grow I think honestly
unlike most in that position it's
impacted me less than a lot of other
[__] my life has impacted me I think I
was just raised purely for like valuing
people who know who you are and who they
like who you are as a man and how you
like act in this world rather than what
you accomplish and what you own and all
these things
and all these people don't know who I am
so even from a young age I literally
remember thinking like all these
compliments I'm getting these people
don't even know who I am these people
don't even like they can say whatever
they want about me but it's just this
idea of me they're talking about not
actually me so the compliments well I'm
grateful for it and the support and it
means a lot to me they don't know who I
am it doesn't make me better or worse
whatever they say so when negativity
comes in and people say anything bad
it's it's they're both wanted the same
they're both just kind of like out there
and it doesn't really mean anything you
know if like my mom came up to me and
like you're being a really [__]
shitty person I'd like what the [__]
like I would like my heart would think I
you know change my whole life but like
if someone on the street comes up and be
like you're this that I'd be like
you don't even know me yeah like what
but how do you
you know your mind isn't actually going
to gravitate toward these meaner
comments we have this negativity bias
that we see yeah
how have you trained yourself do you do
you not look is there a strategy behind
this for how you try and avoid the that
seeping in I imagine if you're three
weeks out from prep with everything in
the toilet and you feel like crap and
you've got 1500 calories to look forward
to today half of which is from broccoli
like the last thing that you want to see
is someone saying something mean on the
internet for sure yeah so why do you go
to deal with that
um I mean it's been there's a lot of
things and it's been a tradition but now
at this point when I'm in prep I mute
everything all notifications are off I
don't look at my comments I don't really
look at anything and I would just rather
that not seep into me kind of Baseline I
can always bring myself back to like
what I said understanding these people
don't know me but I'm obviously still
affected by certain things that hit me
but again if something affects me it's
because of something I have unhealed
inside of myself it comes back to like
where I'm where I'm still hurting not so
much what other people are what they're
thinking of me so like an example of
something that hit me a few years ago
but it was it wasn't online it was
someone in person and they were just
[__] around me were bantering where
guys were like you know we give each
other [__] and he said something like oh
wow when you were a kid like girls must
have been like you're just good looking
tall jacked handsome guy come up to him
and then you open your mouth and they
hear you your voice in that lip and
they're like what the [__] and they're
immediately they're like this [__] this
guy and they leave you alone and I
remember like feeling like a kid again
just getting washed over embarrassment
and just like feeling like [__] like
12 years 15 years old again and I was
like wow like I'm just like I used to be
teased a little bit for my list and I'm
like that's still kind of in there a
little bit but that's not because this
guy's an [__] that's because when I
was a kid someone made me feel like [__]
about it and I never really like gave
that kid like the love and permission
myself being that kid the love and
permission to like be okay with that and
understanding that doesn't represent
himself so I think just taking those
moments and using them as an opportunity
to go inside yourself and kind of like
a give your like younger self a little
bit of love and compassion who like
didn't get it maybe when he was younger
because he felt like alone be able to go
back and try and heal those periods of
your life rather than being angry at the
other person
because I mean that's really all that is
to it because if you're given the power
to the person then you're just focusing
on them and you're going to continuously
live in that pain it doesn't help you
and they don't give a [__] they're just
throwing [__] at you they don't care
what they want you to react it's hard to
not have a chip on your shoulder because
of that though right like how have you
managed to get rid of that wanting to
prove these people wrong and you know
you've seen the ways that people who
were mistreated or or felt lonely uh
when they were younger that can become
malignant right as they grow up have you
is there something does it does a chip
appear on your shoulder every so often
that you want to kind of I was I was
never like there's two people who get
affected by it in different ways and I
was never the one who got angry and like
the chip on my shoulder I kind of like
like felt shitty about myself I like I
felt embarrassed and like yeah you're
right I am [__] stupid I do something
stupid when I talk like I should just
shut up and sit over here in the quiet
like I was more like and it never led to
aggression in me or like a chip on my
shoulder it was more of a like you're
right you are kind of worthless just go
stand over there so that was more of
like that's why when I say what I needed
to work on with more empathy and
compassion for myself and just like
accepting my Humanity my imperfection
rather than like I mean it's also the
same thing but mine was more focused on
like not
shaming myself rather than like bringing
down a level of aggression and anger
tell you what I absolutely love about
that is you saying
I was made to feel shitty lonely sort of
worthless at some point throughout
childhood and your answer to it isn't to
lean into aggression and to push back
against it but to find empathy yeah but
to find empathy that you turn inward
yeah I think that's like just so Noble
so I've told this story before but I was
doing a big podcast last year and um
my strategy typically when I'm doing the
big episodes is I'll stay fasted I end
up being quicker mentally and I didn't
realize how long this episode was going
to go on for part way through I went
hypo so I'm sat there
and my mind goes completely blank like
just [__] nothing I'm like what's
going on I'm so opposite just hearing
something happen like
and I'm thinking to myself why don't you
have anything to say like what's just it
was like it was literally like someone
shook the extra sketch inside of my
brain
it's like [__]
there's nothing there's nothing left
like I I there's nothing for me to
to say and then immediately this voice
came up that said you're not supposed to
be here you were never supposed to be
here everyone's laughing at you everyone
thinks that you're stupid you knew that
this was a fluke uh everybody isn't
interested in what you've got to say
this is your chance and you're blowing
it you're an idiot and I was like whoa
where the [__] has that voice come from
yeah and I realized it was a voice that
I remember from my childhood but it was
one that I thought
I'd know I'd deprogrammed or whatever
but after
in in times of really serious stress
I think uh Old Wounds and old habits and
old traumas like reappear and that was
really really high pressure anyway I
ended up having some coffee and this
caffeine just ripped me out of it and
everything was fine the funniest thing
was that if you actually listen back to
the episode you can't even tell there's
just an autopilot voice that's moving
while internally and no one would know
nobody in the entire world were able to
respond I had a perfectly cogent
conversation well yeah you do anything
long enough yes you become competent at
it but yeah my entire mind was saying
you're a piece of [__] you're worthless
everyone's laughing at you you're stupid
you know you know that this was a fluke
you're not supposed to be here you're
never supposed to be here meanwhile I'm
having a conversation
I'm going to say anything
um but yeah the issue with that is it's
not like the whole point is like when
you felt that it isn't like
if then that becomes another problem so
you're beating yourself up and then it's
a problem that you're beating yourself
up right it's just like a continuous
loop of like this like battle you're
having yourself yeah but if you don't
even think that you forgetting and
beating yourself up is a problem it's
just part of like what happens in The
Human Experience then there's nothing to
fix and it's slowly just like
shift back to normal yeah I think
feeling Shame about the things that you
feel yeah is really really really
destructive and I know that I felt this
for a long time that I should be more
disciplined I should be more competent I
should be more diligent I every single
mistake that I make I Stumble over this
particular I'm supposed to not hit
snooze on the morning and I and I hit
snooze or I I check my phone really
quickly before I go for a walk on the
morning and that means I'm fundamentally
a piece of [__] or this means I'm it's
like there's a an awareness there's like
a alert radar and I'm permanently
looking for reasons to justify that I
might be a piece of [__] I'm just
constantly seeking like a threat
detector but it's not it's a [__]
detector yeah and I'm permanently
looking for reasons to justify to myself
and that was for a long time and this is
you know I'm such a massive fan of
personal development and of personal
growth and of of people improving
themselves but as soon as you posit an
ideal you then begin to compare yourself
to that ideal and that creates a pain
between where you are and where you want
to be yeah and you know I'm all for
trying to maximize your agency make as
much of the time that you have on this
planet as you can
and balancing that desire to be better
with acceptance love empathy for
yourself and the ability to just be
grateful and present in the moment I
think fundamentally for a lot of driven
people that is
that's the battle Yeah I think those are
the two things that they're fighting
with attention and it's it's I mean it's
work it's like constant
working like I still have things that
come up with me that are um like similar
to that like even in this conversation
honestly when you ask me about my
morning routine I'm like
[__] Mr Olympian you don't even have
a morning routine you should be more
structured in the morning and then I was
like what the [__] like you you are Mr
Olympia and you don't have a morning
routine period I don't need to [__]
shame myself after that I'm in this
Olympian I have a morning period And I
can just leave it at that and I honestly
just recently discovered this like
battle in myself which I kind of
mentioned of this expectation that was
on me which like I kind of labeled as
sebum some people call me sebum they
don't know who I am and then there's
Christopher yes there's like that 12
year old Christopher who's just like you
know he's emotional he's anxious he's
stressed out but he's quiet and he's
he's just who he is and then sebum is
[__] confident calm cool collected
can step on stage grab a mic give a
motivational speech Crush Olympia Squad
600 pounds you know he's like the dream
and then that person doesn't exist but
when people continuously call me sebum
treat me like that look up to me like
that that's what builds this like
disconnection myself and I need to
continuously discover who Chris is who
Christopher is go back to who he was who
he is now and like who all these aspects
of myself that are just me and let that
continuously shine through but I think
as like you adapted when you were young
I've adapted or young we create this
thing that fits better into society
rather than just being ourselves because
we want to fit in we want to succeed we
want to be the ideal that we hear and
there was this I think it's brene brown
she talks about it she's a vulnerability
specialist I'm sure you know who she is
she said this thing where is if you show
up in a crowd and your goal is to fit in
then you're putting your self-worth on
the line
but if you show up and your goal is just
to be yourself then you can't fail and
your self-worth is at the end of the day
is if you just act like yourself
everybody can do that and then you leave
feeling good about yourself because you
have control over that but if you're
showing up and you're just doing and
being anything just to be fit into the
crowd and you don't fit in you're not
even being yourself then who the [__]
are you you know you're worthless so
it's a lot easier to just show up and
make the goal to be seen rather than to
be accepted because that's who you are
and it's in your control
there's a problem as well that I found
especially in my 20s so as this sort of
big name on campus club promoter for 15
years right now massive events company
meet millions of people and the guy
that's really well known I'm on the
front door of nightclubs etc etc etc
and
I never felt love for the achievements
that I had during that and I think a big
part was because I was playing a persona
and I came to believe this is an Aubrey
Marcus thing I know you're a fan of his
as well
um he says the Persona is incapable of
receiving love it can only receive
praise
the reason is that if you're not
genuinely
existentially connected from your heart
to the things that you're doing any
praise that you get isn't going to
actually impact you emotionally because
you're not emotionally connected you're
cognitively connected that you go over
here can get the praise because
congratulations you did really well
Christopher meanwhile is still a
worthless piece of [__] for 12 years
just sat there watching sebum precisely
correct yeah and you know it goes back
to the parable of the Mexican fishermen
thing or like what are you optimizing
for with regards to success
do you want to make it to the end of
your life with all of the public
accolades that anybody could want
feeling completely unfulfilled
internally let alone and alone lost or
do you want to dial back what you do in
the real world so that it actually
matches up with who you are
and move both of those people forward
and
you know it's that's why I think that
you're a really great Champion for the
introverted and quiet you know in a
world of of guys that get rich off Egos
and and being loud and sort of out there
you know Andrew Tate like [__]
fantastic speaker Great Communicator
um
but
a very different sort of person to you
for sure
and yet both role models for men both
people that are very highly followed
online both people who you know embody
masculinity in incredibly different ways
but
yeah I think it's very important that we
have a a counterbalance for the sort of
introverted quiet kid it's hard because
like you said social media is like
targeted towards the extroverted loud
controversial the people who are like
Andrew Tate who are just going out there
like captures people's attention people
like me like I always joke about it I'm
always like when I'm done I'm gonna move
to the mountains no cell phone service
No One's Gonna have my address you'll
never find me you know people like me
want to go hide you know people like
Andrew are like where's the spotlight I
got [__] to say you know and it's it's
hard to balance that and I I've also
learned that I'm actually less
introverted than I even thought it was
I'm just more like
afraid to show myself essentially so it
was easier just to kind of hide in the
background when I start to feel
comfortable and be myself and I'm like
out there I'm like I actually kind of
enjoy this more than I realized as long
as I'm showing myself truly and I'm not
feeling like I need to put on this
facade that's the Persona thing again
right exactly if you start to play that
I actually think that it
even though publicly you may be more
competent because you have created this
Mirage out in front of the person who's
lost and alone and and insecure
it actually makes going out and doing it
more and more difficult and this is how
you see you know guys like Avicii the DJ
as a good example somebody who publicly
was having to do something that
privately he didn't feel uh alignment
with and they end up in really bad
situations yeah given obviously you are
a role model for men mentioned Andrew
Tate there also another role model for
men how much do you interact how much do
you think about sort of the state of
modern masculinity at the moment and the
challenges that young men are facing
I've recently started to think about it
a lot more I think it's been surfacing
more and
it's it's it's a weird like balance
because people like Andrew Tate are
saying like we need more masculinity we
need more aggression we need like X Y
and Z and I think there's
that I agree with that on one level for
like a little bit but there's also a
section of men who just feel alone like
myself who felt like they have to hold
things in that they shouldn't share
their emotions that they don't lean on
people and that they should just carry
stuff in and they need to be X Y and Z
to be like good enough so there's this
like balance of that and you almost need
to learn to again like I mentioned like
that the masculine and The Feminine
being able to integrate that I feel like
a real man is confident and comfortable
enough to embrace the feminine energy he
has in him if he's emotional let it out
but also have that masculine side of it
be like I'm gonna be emotional right now
but I'm still going to go and [__] [__]
up right now you know I'm still going to
take charge of what I want with my life
I'm going to work [__] hard to be
this one but I'm going to accept that
sometimes I'm gonna break down and it's
gonna be I'm not saying that women break
down but there's more emotion over there
and allow it to feel it and to ask for
help and to lean on people and be able
to balance those two in that like yin
and yang I think I think that's what's
missing personally and I do like on one
level I do feel a sense of
responsibility because the fitness to
the big world of men who are I think
usually get into Fitness on some level
maybe feeling lost and then can feel a
little bit safe and I heard a lot of
people be like I can go in the gym and
just forget about everything I'm like
that's great the gym is an amazing tool
for that but you still need to go back
and feel that [__] eventually because
it's not going away a good workout
doesn't make the stress at home better
now it's still just buried under that
[__] dopamine Russian sick pump you
got in your chest you know it's still
there so I think just learning to
navigate and balance that is super
important and that's where I'm like okay
I'm someone right now where people look
up to on one level there's a
responsibility for me
let's take my 12 year old self
who felt like he had to hold it all
together he couldn't lean on anyone he
couldn't ask for help and I just
remember this time I was in the hospital
a few years ago and I didn't tell my
parents I didn't want to tell them
because I didn't want them to be
stressed and anxious and then they found
out and I was like it's okay like don't
come I'm totally fine like they were out
of town or we live in different cities
and like don't even bother coming I'll
be out of here in no time it's okay and
I thought about that and I broke down
crying again I was like why didn't I ask
for help I felt so scared and alone and
just to have my mom sitting beside me
I'm a man I'm 20 years old at the time
it would have felt better but why am I
so scared to ask for help you know like
why do you think you are scared to ask
about
part of my childhood of just feeling
like hey I saw my dad who didn't really
need help my mom was busy they were both
super busy with work and they gave me
everything that they could but they came
from families who didn't know how to
show them kind of love and support and
they came from so there's all these
generations of this pain who don't know
how to express themselves and then I
think honestly my parents jumped about
tension worth of progress of who they
are and how they showed me love and
vulnerability as much as they could but
there's still stuff missing and now I
would like to jump a few Generations as
well and hopefully help my kids but
there's always a gap of where the kid
where we're gonna miss something and I
think a lot of that does come from my
childhood and then so when I get in
situations like that I was afraid to ask
for help and now I look back and I'm
just like
if I had you started crying and been
like I need you mom like I would have
felt so much better yeah but I had to be
like no I'm okay don't even come I'm
good I mean sit in this hospital by
myself and stare at the wall and just
try not to think about dying you know
like that's [__] insane I don't know
why I did that what would you say okay
so you know there's a lot of guys
listening who say that that resonates
with me I feel like I struggle to open
up like I
find it hard to embrace the fears and
the insecurities and stuff that I have
what have you found
as a good first step or as the first
steps that's good for those guys to take
to move forward
it's it's definitely tough and it's
depending on the situation in your life
and this is kind of where I was getting
at is like hopefully myself
if I think of who I would have wanted to
be as a role model to that 12 year old
boy that's who I should be in this world
to anyone who is looking up to me now so
I hope that some people like me who
Express this stuff can at least give
permission for people to start that
Journey so if I have that if I have that
impact on anyone and I've had people
come up to me and like a q a and [__]
like I wanted to ask you this but like
I'm [__] going like tell me some
crazy story where I'm about to cry
listening to them and they're coming to
share it with me and I'm like [__] man
like that's that's deep you need some
like you need people to lean on and
they're like I don't know what to do so
my advice for those people would be to
understand that hopefully you have
someone in your life who loves you and
if they love you they want to help you
they might not know how to ask you
because they weren't given that help so
sometimes you have to put yourself out
there and be like and just open yourself
up to them and allow them to see deep
inside you because not everyone can read
your mind and like dive deep into your
school just because you're like you have
a different look on your face today or
something you know so if you have people
you love lean into them and if you
really don't feel safe with anyone in
your life that's scary and I'm like I
feel horrible for anyone who feels that
alone but find a therapist or something
I initially I did have people I could
lean on and loved in my life but I went
to a therapist before even them and back
in 2020 when I told you that thing I
don't really want to I can't talk about
that was really hard on me I buried all
that and I went to a therapist and
started talking to them and I thought
I'd never be able to open up to someone
some stranger I don't know first session
[__] crying on this couch and I was
like holy [__] there's a lot of stuff
inside me right now and so much of my
journey for the last five years I've
been understanding how much stuff I've
suppressed and didn't know what was
there and allow it to come up and the
amount of like the how light my heart
feels and how light my body feels when I
kind of get some of that out it just
helped me so much you can tell you can
really tell that you feel more sort of
aligned just like yeah I just feel good
with myself overall and I know like I
said earlier got emotional just thinking
about like the people I've had in my
life and now it was Courtney the amount
our relationship has built over the span
of time of me being able to bring myself
out more and share with her or like we
were engaged and now I'm like I don't
[__] even know what a ring is but I'm
gonna [__] die with this girl by my
side because nothing's gonna tear us
apart because I just rebuilt that
connection through that trust
remembering what you said about um
don't necessarily expect people to be
able to pick up on the fact that your
face looks a bit different today yeah
she had to ask you four times yeah in
the bathroom yeah now I was lucky as
hell that she's such a empath type of
human she's super emotional and she was
able to see me but if not who knows if I
would have shared that over there yeah I
either uh empath or
um unrelenting perhaps but both I'm
gonna keep on asking and keep on asking
me keep on poking yeah I I really do
think that this
this tension we talked about this
attention between a desire for success
and a feeling of being enough
um between wanting to be strong and
competent and also being able to
integrate the emotions that you have
it is so so individual and the point is
that
trying to take any philosophy any one
Philosophy from someone and saying I am
going to take the Andrew Tate or I'm
going to take the Chris bumsteader I'm
going to take the Chris Williamson
approach to this sort of a thing
fundamentally doesn't work because the
drivers that you have are completely
different yeah and I think that the only
thing which really does scale is okay
try and find out what's true
in you try and find out how you actually
feel about these things I have a friend
who's staying in Austin at the moment
guy called George and when anybody asks
him about his childhood and everyone's
supposed to got like [__] from their
childhood he has nothing he has
absolutely nothing like is my childhood
was fantastic do you ever get bullied no
I had loads of good friends and I have
no baggage I have no trauma I have no
nothing so for him the solution is
completely different yeah solution is
completely different to the one that it
is for maybe me or you and yeah I think
there's still a potential that he's
looking back with rose-colored glasses
oh yeah and that he just kind of pushed
a few small things aside and now some
stuff might make him feel triggered or
insecure embarrassing he just like oh
that's normal just kind of push it over
and move on but he doesn't even see it
I'm not saying that's true it might be
but it's possible if he breaks down
crying this week in the just go home and
poke him like are you good are you good
yeah good five times yeah five times how
do you think about breaking that stigma
that like both can coexist in a alpha
male too for men you know like you can
be this [__] killer who cries you know
like you can and I mean I'm not a deep
religious person but you look at someone
like Jesus Christ the night before he
got crucified the Bible says he was
weeping you know he was scared when he
was carrying the cross he was stumbling
he was falling he had to have people
help him like this is the epitome of the
archetypal like human you know and he
struggled he cried he was scared and he
was sacrificed for everyone like that's
a story the oldest time that was equally
showing that but you don't think Jesus
was a [__] badass [__] like I
think he probably was you know so I
think there's a there's an ability to
intertwine that and sometimes people
come out of the Woodworks like Andrew
Tate who are just so far one away like
this is being a man and then there's
people who are too far the other way who
like you need to be sensitive and cry
and who cares about winning and all this
[__] it's like no like I want to be the
best version of myself and that's my
biggest goal but underneath that I want
to [__] win I want to [__]
embarrass everybody on stage but when I
don't I'm not any less of a man I'm
still just as like I still value myself
I'm just as worthy of a human being
let's just I still want to [__] [__]
[__] up over there you know to be able
to intertwine that and just believe that
they can coexist I think it's something
just super important to set off on that
Journey you uh I the first thing I asked
you was about pressure as a privilege
and you mentioned that it was like just
the thing that you came up with and then
you almost retrofitted the the idea
around it the same thing goes for a
champion mentality you like come up with
a thing I have a friend Mary and she
says a meme first uh meme first explain
later and I think that it's really
really important that you have
um
concept that can be quite easily
summarized the parable of the Mexican
fishermen yeah everybody knows what that
is everyone knows that story they know
what the takeaways are one of the
problems that you have with a meme first
explain later philosophy is that you
optimize for ideas that are very simple
and like unidimensional so holding two
opposing thoughts in your mind at the
same time is like the most difficult
thing that you can do in 2023 yeah I
want to be strong and powerful but open
and vulnerable okay like no these these
two think you have to be just one or the
other that's the only way that it works
so I do think that like
The Limited bandwidth that the internet
has and some of the
um
ways that people are rewarded for
Content online
causes them to simplify down theories
and philosophies to the point where you
lose the nuance and the Nuance is really
what's important yeah and it actually
causes cultural means to propagate that
are
nowhere near as sophisticated as they
should be like if any one concept can be
explained in a single sentence it's
probably not sufficiently complex you
know for sure yeah especially I think
the biggest tool that they come from
that those like Parables or quotes or
whatever have come with me was just like
giving me a reason to self-reflect so
when I hear like a quote or like a story
or something I've said in the past that
really like I'm like [__] that kind of
like hits me I'll like write it down and
I'll continuously go back and kind of
rethink what it means to me you know and
I think we all need to learn how to
really think for ourselves so when you
listen to someone like we keep going
after Andrew take it you brought them up
when he goes on this I listen to part of
his huge podcast and there's all this
[__] I'm like [__] like this dude's
smart I'm fired up like this this all
makes sense and he said something and
I'm like I don't agree with that like I
don't for myself that's if it works for
him okay but like I don't so I don't
have to agree with everything he's
saying but I have to be smart enough to
be able to think for myself to take
pieces of both sides and understand them
politics want us to lean right or left
that like it's somewhere in the middle
at the end of the day and you have to
like you said you have to find your own
way some level you have it's constant
reflection of finding who you are and
finding out where you fit and all this
and how it integrates into you not just
because person X does it like this but
because you do it the best way you do it
you have to learn through mistakes and
through practice and reflection and life
and Triumph and pairing and all this
[__] you know well when you have someone
that gets a platform
any platform they are usually a
specialist in one particular area
another particular one good at one
particular thing the problem is that
they then because social media is
ubiquitous and 24 7. they then asked
their opinion on other things like I
will quite happily take your advice on a
good push-pull leg split but to be frank
I don't care what you think about the
Ukraine conflict you know what I mean
I'm not gonna give them a part of this
yes but there are a lot of people who
we've got the opportunity to have this
platform so when do you think about the
kovid Wuhan lab leak hypothesis and what
do you think about the situation that
we've got going on with Russia and blah
blah blah I think staying in your lane
in that regard is is a good idea and
even that you know coming from someone
that does have a platform even that's
tempting oh right maybe I could become
the what if I was the Ukraine guy yeah
as well I have a friend Douglas Murray
and he said um
somebody asked him why he hadn't
commented very much
on the covid situation it's like back
end of 2021 or start 2022. we've been
through this two-year I mean in the same
thing and he writes four or five columns
a week and it's a big big deal and he
barely comments on it yeah and he said
I'm going to do something which is very
rare in the modern world which is to not
say anything about something which I
know nothing about imagine that [__]
brilliant yeah so one of the things that
we've spoken about today common theme
has been an investigation into your own
mind right introspective retrospective
doing that ruminative work have you ever
had any interest in psychedelics
yes have you taken any I haven't I'm so
tempted though yeah I'm like constantly
like I want to go to prove and do
Ayahuasca like I want the journey to hit
me with it I just I mean I'm there's
there's still a part of me that's like a
little bit afraid you know you hear all
the like this I do believe what people
say when like one of the common fears is
like you're not going to want anything
that's currently in your life and then
the con the contrary to that is like
well it's because those things weren't
meant to be in your life but I do
believe that but I also love my life
right now and I don't really think I
need that much of a change and I'm
slowly mentally growing and like
becoming more true to myself and happy
and I don't really want to [__] with
that but the shroom side of things I'm
sure I'll dabble eventually yeah I just
haven't gotten there yet yeah yeah yeah
I know uh so mushrooms yeah but nothing
I haven't tried LSD I haven't tried
Ayahuasca I mean Austin which is the
Psychedelic capital of America and um
yeah a lot of people go down to saltara
I think it's called a lot of the guys
fly down there I want to say that that's
maybe in Peru
um
it sounds fantastic I mean actually the
process doesn't sound that nice up until
the point in which you're in it but
yeah there's definitely fear I think uh
and apprehension around okay what's this
going to bring up the you know
especially if you've done some work and
you realize that there's depth to trauma
yeah and you think wow there is some
some stuff that came up that one time
when I was on a podcast and you go okay
what if I think I've relieved all of the
pressure that was tamping down that and
it's not just [__] I haven't even
touched it yeah yeah
it's scary I mean and that's part of the
I mean the fear of even self-reflection
it's a baby version of just like
uncovering what's inside you that you've
been suppressing forever like what's
deep inside Chris yeah otherwise or
Chris you know sending it can all pour
out and you have no idea what you're
gonna do
I saw you post about the difference
between seeing a dream as a fantasy and
seeing it as an objective that you guys
had been playing around with words and
definitions and how important they were
yeah what is that difference what's the
difference between seeing a dream as a
fantasy and a dream is an objective yeah
I was kind of just reflecting on
I I think a lot about language too and I
try and correct the way I say things and
like people call me up for it now my
YouTube and it helps me a lot and I just
think the there's a lot of power and
words that reflects a lot but it's not
so much the word but it's each
individual's perception of that word
and it was just more of a thought
because we made this I said this thing
like dream with intent and it was just
like what is a dream mean like anyone
can ask you a question and you're like
what's your definition of this word in
that question and it could be completely
different
so if I say dream somebody could be like
well I'm fantasizing about this but in
their mind they're like someone who
works nine to five and they're
fantasizing of their dream job that they
know they're gonna do because it's just
a dream
and then there's the type of person who
hears dream and it's like well it's same
it's not in a synonymous with goal it's
just an objective I'm gonna get it's
just my Top Line objective and I think
even just like starting something and be
like this is my dream if that means that
too great but maybe you should switch
that word to this is my goal this is my
objective this is what I'm chasing after
so you're actually committing a plan of
action to yourself rather than just some
like fantasy that you have in your sleep
one of the best things I heard about
this was
a lot of people are worried about giving
up what they have now for what is going
to happen in future especially it comes
to do with work right that you have a
job which is okay it's not great but
it's not that bad
and you end up realizing are you
succeeding at a job that you hate yes
imagine how well you would succeed at a
job that you loved yeah and it's crazy
it's crazy to think that
is it I think 85 of Americans say that
they are either actively unengaged or
not engaged with their work it's only 15
of people that say I am actively engaged
with my work yeah so you have 85 percent
of people that are basically ambivalent
or like outright negative about the
thing that they spend 40 hours a week
doing yeah
and
not everybody can just up sticks and
decide to Pivot and go and do different
stuff but that's the point that
everybody faces that same level of
difficulty and that when it becomes
tough or you're uncertain or whatever
everybody else faces that as well yeah
so it's almost like
when you're deep in a diet and your body
is pushing you to try and eat more food
but you're stopping it from eating more
food yeah that's not an enjoyable
feeling but it is the sign that progress
is being made and it's the same thing as
when
a lot of guys message me and ask about
uh I don't necessarily have the support
system around me that I wish that I did
to be able to do the things that I want
to I live in the north west of England
and you know I love reading philosophy
or psychology and learning about human
nature but all of my friends are like
rugby players and all they want to do is
go out and drink every weekend and I'm I
used to be like that and maybe now I'm
not and I'm starting to feel a
discontinuity and Discord and friction
between me and the life that I used to
live in the life that I Live Now and
where I want to go
um how can I deal with the fact that
this is painful for me
and the answer is the fact that it is
painful is the reason that it's working
yeah if it wasn't
you stepping out everybody else that has
to try and step out into this new life
faces this same thing too every single
person does that's why most people don't
do it yeah like this is what hard feels
like and this is why most people don't
win
so continuing to push through and almost
seeing that level of discomfort as a
signal it's like a way marker that's
been planted in the ground yes more this
way because if it was all just super
easy well how are you going to get
anything different to what everybody
else has got if you do the same thing
that everybody else does yeah and one of
the best selectors for people not doing
a thing is discomfort so the route that
has a lot of discomfort down it usually
on the other side of that ends up with
something which is valuable usually
usually if you know where your progress
is going correct like to build on that
one you were talking about like the
progress part A lot of them so it kills
a lot of people is like what are you
progressing towards people who sit in
their jobs and they feel like there's no
value there's not contributing to
themselves or the world or really it's
just there for a paycheck that then it
feels like tough like uncomfortable
though there's just you know this you're
just miserable with it but at least your
friend if he's chasing after something
that's like a dream of his or a passion
that he's chasing towards and his
progress that's uncomfortable at least
at the end of that line it's what he
wants yep you know that's leads to
obviously like a lot of people ask me
how do you say so like you mentioned
discipline when you're at that point you
want to eat and you're on a diet like
well I love what I do at the Baseline
I'm passionate about what I'm doing and
I love what the goal will be I love the
part of it I love the impact it has on
others but help people in my life and
myself so at the end that's just there's
a reason there's a purpose behind it
rather than just mindlessly circling the
hamster wheel yeah one of my friends uh
Chris Sparks has this idea called there
is no growth without goals and what he
means is that the
James Clear Atomic habit's idea of you
know just focus on daily routines and
you don't need to be outcome focused you
just need to be iteration focused just
do one day do one day do one day yeah
but that only works if it is in service
of a greater thing yes you are going to
not rise to the level of your goals
you're going to fall to the level of
your systems but your systems need to be
moving you in the right direction
because if you end up realizing oh I've
been doing all of this stuff day after
day after day and the destination it's
taken me to is something that I wasn't
even really that bothered about that
this happens all the time people that
think all I need to do is continue to
grow the business one day after the next
I'm going to turn up on time I'm going
to work hard I'm going to do the rest of
the thing and in 20 years they look back
and go I didn't want a big business
never cared yeah I can do anything with
all this money now I spent all of this
time climbing up a ladder to realize
that it's up against the wrong wall yeah
so yeah there can be no growth without
goals and I think that it's important
but also being too outcome focused again
holding two conflicting thoughts in your
mind at the same time yes it's difficult
it's difficult but it's important and
even that even in this that we're
talking about
the fact that it's hard to hold two
different thoughts in your mind at one
time is the exact thing that separates
you out from the rest of the crowd
because that's what most people do most
people struggle to do hold those things
for sure so if you can do it that's also
another selector yeah but yes Ayahuasca
I would love to see you do it I wonder
what sort of size dose they would need
to give you I bet they're gonna have to
give you a big boy dose I don't know I
feel like I'm I can still be a
lightweight yeah
when are you gonna stop when you're
going to be done am I going to stop when
are you going to be done the million
dollar question right now
the last few years I've been getting
asked out a lot I think because I
went through a tough period at one point
where I wasn't thriving in bodybuilding
and I wasn't enjoying it too much and I
think I almost like hinted in my energy
that this wasn't like going to be
forever and people like he's gonna
retire so now I get that question all
the time but since integrating myself
more into this like I was speaking about
the sea bombers Christopher being myself
more allowing myself to feel the stress
sometimes makes me more excited about
the good parts and feel all the joy
rather than just numbing stuff out it's
actually made it a lot more fun overall
I'm a lot more excited every year now
and I look forward to it so every year
now I'm like excited to keep going to be
better and I've always told myself again
I tell myself these things if I come to
the point where I'm not excited or I'm
not like looking forward to like pushing
myself and going past with limits again
and I'm like oh like [__] like when I
have those days but I mean consistent
like that's how I truly feel about it
then I need to pull it because I don't
think without that like love and drive
and passion that I'm gonna be able to
push my body to the limits of where I'm
actually capable of being my best self
and I don't want to compete to win
another title I don't want to look worse
someone a title I want to know that I'm
progressing and I'm like beating what I
look like last year which how [__]
miserable it was to get down to that
that body fat and to keep that muscle on
me and to train like that and do all
that I want to know I can beat that this
year that's part of what excites me even
more than the trophy does so as soon as
I lose that fire I gotta tell myself I'm
tapping out and I'm ready for the next
part of life but I'm truly taking it
year by year and it sounds like a bit of
a political answer but I honestly I look
to the next year and I'm like if I
finish this here and I'm like [__] yeah
let's do it again then I'll do it again
but if I'm like nope this isn't it for
me like over extended period of time I
truly my heart I'm done then I'm gonna
check out but I really I can't predict
the future again my health comes into it
my health starts to deteriorate then
I'll be gone but I've been
functioning in a way where I like I know
I have a lot set up post career you know
I've never identified myself as a
bodybuilder I don't really even like to
like dress looking like I'm this [__]
Jack bodybuilder in a tight white v-neck
guy they look tiny I'm just like a
skinny guy who walks through the street
you know but like I don't identify
myself as such so when I'm done
bodybuilding it's not like oh no who am
I now this loss of this loss of self no
it's just a chapter of My Life the book
is closed let's open a new one what's
next so just creating a structure right
now and a self where there's no fear
around leaving it it'll be sad as
[__] I will forever miss being the
strong the shredded this big the
standing on stage the feeling on their
lights hearing my name called but it's
the time and place for it and I'm
enjoying it right now and when it's gone
it'll just be time for the next thing
and then fatherhood yes
that's that's like my my thing and I
still like if I'm lucky enough to have
kids it's like I just I put that little
that little safety cynicism that on
myself because there's always a fear
behind that but I just truly think like
I'm gonna be the best dad ever my fiance
will be the best mom ever and I'm like
I'm [__] looking forward to that I'm
like very excited to have kids and like
all I hear a lot of people say that
they're scared to bring their kids into
this world go to the shape of where it's
at and how like crazy things are now
but I'm like no like that's exciting
like I'm gonna bring a badass kid and
he's gonna [__] own this [__] because
I I'll teach him how to navigate it and
I'll give him permission to do all the
stuff that I've learned and I'll teach
him everything I've learned and I'm
really excited to like build that kind
of family unit and hopefully pass on
some knowledge I've learned over years
and what my parents gave me and what
I've expanded on that and put that into
another human yeah me too I can't wait
to be a dad and the the difference
between a parent's generation and Oz an
odd generation and the next one I really
really hope will be a big inflection
point our parents did fantastic they did
as well as they could but the difference
in the amount of information that's
available the self-growth the personal
work that you've been able to do that
I've been able to do you know you have
the opportunity right now if you're
listening to this to access the greatest
thinkers on the planet 24 7. in real
time for free directly into your ears it
is such an unbelievable privilege to be
able to have that it is [__] insane
you can not like the way that you feel
you cannot like the texture of your own
mind the way that you experience the
world and you have the opportunity to be
able to go out and learn the exact thing
that you need to be able to improve that
go away work on it come back listen to
the same person again it's [__]
insane yeah it's absolutely ridiculous
that we have the opportunity to do this
and it is
such a huge opportunity
I asked David Goggins because he David
Goggins his father had been mistreated
by his grandfather goggins's grandfather
and then his father mistreated David and
I asked David whether he almost saw it
as part of his mission to be a like a
dam to be a Breakwater of a circuit
breaker from all of this trauma you know
that's getting passed down from
generation to generation and I I think
that a degree of awareness you know all
of the challenges that young men are
facing at the moment where they wish
that they'd been able to speak up more
integrate the feminine learn to embody
the masculine whatever it might be I
really really hope and think that in you
know 20 years time when the next
Generation like the millennial personal
development bro generation kids are
growing up that they're actually going
to be like you know what it was I
[__] I learned so much from my dad
like I just he downloaded like every
Jordan Peterson and Joe Rogan Insight
directly into my brain by the age of 10
years old can you imagine that
generation yeah I think it's really
exciting but I feel like it would be
like a without everyone's taking
advantage some people are just growing
Tick Tock with this use of the internet
so it'll be like those people and then
no one's down here and it'll be dealing
with an audible subscription and people
without notable subscription exactly it
yeah I I do agree I think it's called
assortative mating in um like the The
evolutionary psychology literature and
uh people that are alike mate the people
that are alike mate and that ends up
with you know the personal growth people
make with the personal growth people and
the people that The Tick Tock people
make with the tick tock people and you
do end up you're right you do end up
with this almost diverging
um
quality of insight like the polarizing
group yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which is
not good but on the flip side like what
are you gonna do like you're reaching
20 million people across all of your
socials you know if if you can't nudge
culture then nobody can for sure so but
yeah man I I think
the opportunity and it really sounds
like the work that you've done is almost
preparing yourself to become a a good
dad in a way I love the idea of most of
the battles that you go through in your
20s being the thing that prepares you to
be the father that you want to be in
your 30s yeah I really think that that's
a very Noble way of thinking about and
also it you know it's not like you
didn't get anything out of it either but
for sure you also get
this beautiful opportunity to pass on
more insights to a child
that were hard won by you I think that's
really really cool for sure yeah why
it's so important in your 20s to throw
yourself into the fire to take the risks
and if there's going to be a moment in
your life where you're like [__] it I'm
just gonna go for it and if I fail
a fail do it in your 20s you know take
the risks do the things that are
uncomfortable and kind of like navigate
yourself through it because they're
really putting yourself in those
uncomfortable situations like you said
that uncomfort equals growth so you kind
of gotta do it
[__] yeah Chris bumpstead ladies and
gentlemen Chris let's bring this one
home I really appreciate you man thank
you for having me why should people go
if they want to check out all of the
[__] that you're doing at the moment I
could just look up Chris bum said I can
find it brand name by name yeah
relatively brand name rare
Dagwood bump said famous from the old
newspapers in the 70s or some [__] okay
dude thank you so much for having me I
appreciate you yeah no I'm super
grateful to be here I've watched your
podcast for a while so it's an honor to
be sitting in front of you in this
intimidating interview as people like to
comment